Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In 1920, the country of Ireland consisted of two self-governing territories, Northern Ireland and Southern Ireland, both of which belonged to the United Kingdom. Following the War of Independence and the Anglo-Irish Treaty of 1921, Southern Ireland declared independence from the UK and became the Republic of Ireland, while Northern Ireland
我们的节目探讨的都是严肃且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要帮助，请联系您当地的危机干预中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。1920年，爱尔兰由两个自治领土组成，即北爱尔兰和南爱尔兰，这两个领土都属于大不列颠及北爱尔兰联合王国。在独立战争和1921年《英爱条约》之后，南爱尔兰宣布脱离英国独立，成为爱尔兰共和国，而北爱尔兰
remained under British rule. This partitioning caused great conflict between the two regions, with Irish nationalists in the Republic wanting all of Ireland to be reunified as an independent country, while Unionists in the North didn't agree. Many inhabitants of Northern Ireland were descended from English ancestors and identified more as British instead of Irish, hence their loyalty to the UK. The fact that the Unionists were mainly of Protestant background, while the nationalists were predominantly Catholic, only furthered the divide.
则继续由英国统治。这种分割导致了两个地区之间的巨大冲突，共和国的爱尔兰民族主义者希望整个爱尔兰重新统一为一个独立国家，而北方的统一派则不同意这一点。北爱尔兰的许多居民是英国祖先的后代，他们认同自己是英国人而不是爱尔兰人，因此他们对英国忠心耿耿。统一派主要是新教背景，而民族主义者则主要是天主教徒，这一事实进一步加深了隔阂。
In 1968, a period known as the Troubles began, marking a battle for control between those who thought Northern Ireland should be returned to the Republic and to those who felt it should remain under British rule. Leading the charge was the Irish Republican Army, or IRA, also known as the Provisional Irish Republican Army. The IRA was an illegal paramilitary organisation whose primary goal was to force the United Kingdom to negotiate a withdrawal from Northern Ireland. They sought to bring about unification of Ireland through any means, including violence
1968年，被称为“动荡时期”（The Troubles）的时期开始了，这标志着主张北爱尔兰归还共和国的人与认为北爱尔兰应继续由英国统治的人之间争夺控制权的斗争。带头的是爱尔兰共和军（简称IRA，也称为临时爱尔兰共和军）。爱尔兰共和军是一个非法的准军事组织，其首要目标是迫使英国谈判撤出北爱尔兰。他们企图通过包括暴力
and terrorism. When the Troubles began, fighting between the IRA and British soldiers from Northern Ireland was at an all-time high. Over the years, the IRA bombed political and economic targets across Northern Ireland and England, using guerrilla tactics in both urban and rural areas. Years of extreme protesting and violence had culminated in low morale and widespread despair throughout Ireland, and the economy was in trouble, resulting in high unemployment rates and mass emigration.
和恐怖主义在内的任何手段实现爱尔兰的统一。动荡时期开始时，爱尔兰共和军与来自北爱尔兰的英国士兵之间的战斗达到了空前的高潮。多年来，爱尔兰共和军在北爱尔兰和英格兰各地轰炸了政治和经济目标，在城市和农村地区都使用了游击战术。多年的极端抗议和暴力活动导致爱尔兰全国士气低落、绝望情绪蔓延，经济也陷入困境，导致高失业率和大规模移民。
Yet, one industry that continued to thrive was horse racing, which provided 20,000 jobs and attracted large sums of money from overseas. In 1980, an Irish racehorse named Surgar took the industry by storm, becoming a racing champion and national treasure. The Irish public adored Surgar, and watching him achieve great success provided a much-needed distraction from the Troubles. He became a symbol of hope and possibility in an otherwise bleak and trying time. Surgar was born on March 3, 1978 at Cheshoun, a private stud farm in the Irish county of
然而，赛马业是一个继续蓬勃发展的行业，它提供了2万个就业岗位，并吸引了大量来自海外的资金。1980年，一匹名叫“舒尔加”（Shergar）的爱尔兰赛马风靡整个行业，成为了赛马冠军和国家宝藏。爱尔兰公众对舒尔加喜爱有加，看着他取得巨大成功，为人们从动荡中转移注意力提供了急需的出口。在一个原本阴暗艰难的时期，他成为了希望和可能性的象征。“舒尔加”于1978年3月3日出生在爱尔兰
Kildare. His father was a British-born thoroughbred racehorse named Great Nephew, and his mother was Charmaine, a thoroughbred who had produced many other successful racehorses throughout her breeding career. Surgar was a quintessential thoroughbred. He was tall and lean, with an athletic build ideal for racing. He had a light brown coat with a black mane and tail, and four white socks on his legs. Running down his nose was a wide white stripe, known as a blaze, and one of his eyes was blue,
基尔代尔郡的一家名为切肖恩（Cheshoun）的私人种马场。他的父亲是一匹英国出生的纯血赛马“伟大的侄子”（Great Nephew），母亲是“夏曼”（Charmaine），一匹在育种生涯中繁殖出许多其他成功赛马的纯血母马。舒尔加是典型的纯血马。他身材高大修长，体格健壮，非常适合赛马。他有着浅棕色的皮毛，黑色鬃毛和尾巴，四条腿上长着四只白色的蹄子。他的鼻梁上有一道宽宽的白条，被称为流星斑，他的其中一只眼睛是蓝色的，
a phenomenon called a walleye. Some horse racing professionals believed that horses with a walleye are predisposed to being skittish and temperamental, but trainers who worked with Surgar dismissed this theory, finding him laid back and easy to train. The Cheshoun stud farm was owned by Prince Karim, a Muslim leader, better known in the West as his Highness Aga Khan IV. As the 49th spiritual leader of the Shia Ismaili Muslims, the Aga Khan is believed to be a direct descendant of the Prophet Muhammad.
这种现象被称为“斜视眼”或“瓦眼”。一些赛马专业人士认为，长有瓦眼的马往往容易受到惊吓和性情急躁，但与舒尔加合作过的驯马师驳斥了这种理论，他们发现舒尔加性格悠闲，很容易训练。切肖恩种马场由穆斯林领袖卡里姆王子（Prince Karim）拥有，他在西方更为人所知的名字是阿迦汗四世殿下（His Highness Aga Khan IV）。作为什叶派伊斯玛仪派穆斯林的第49位精神领袖，阿迦汗被认为是先知穆罕默德的直系后裔。
Shia Islam has an estimated 15 million followers, and the Aga Khan is considered to be their king and spiritual guide. In 1957, he inherited his position from his grandfather, Aga Khan III, at the age of 20, and grew up to be a business magnate, humanitarian worker, and a racehorse breeder. During his time as leader, the Aga Khan has been celebrated for his exceptional contributions to human development and has received numerous awards and honorary degrees from institutions throughout the world. He is also a billionaire, who has been described by Forbes magazine as one of the world's
什叶派伊斯兰教估计有1500万信徒，阿迦汗被认为是他们的国王和精神向导。1957年，他在20岁时从祖父阿迦汗三世那里继承了这一职位，后来成长为一名商业大亨、人道主义工作者和赛马育种家。在其担任领袖期间，阿迦汗因对人类发展的杰出贡献而受到赞誉，并获得了来自世界各地机构的众多奖项和荣誉学位。他还是一个亿万富翁，被《福布斯》杂志描述为世界
10 richest royals. Over the years, the Aga Khan has amassed assets such as valuable stud farms, hundreds of award-winning racehorses, an exclusive Italian yacht club, a private island in the Bahamas, several estates, and two jets. Sherga was trained to be a racehorse from a young age and grew up to become one of the Aga Khan's greatest success stories, known for his nice temperament and for having a certain elegance in the way he moved. He was more relaxed and affectionate than the average thoroughbred, which appealed to
十大王室富豪之一。多年来，阿迦汗积累了宝贵的资产，例如珍贵的种马场、数百匹屡获殊荣的赛马、一个独家意大利游艇俱乐部、巴哈马群岛的一个私人岛屿、几个庄园和两架喷气式飞机。“舒尔加”从小就被训练成一匹赛马，长大后成为阿迦汗最成功的代表作之一，以其温顺的性格和某种优雅的步伐而闻名。他比一般的纯血马更加放松和亲人，这吸引了
his owners and the public, who nicknamed him Ireland's Pegasus. One of Sherga's most endearing features was that when he galloped at full pace, his tongue lulled out the side of his mouth, which one racing commentator said made him look like a 10-year-old solving a tricky maths problem. Sherga's trainer was Michael Stout, a Barbados native hired by the Aga Khan in 1978. Regarded as an up-and-comer, Michael had worked as an assistant to famous British horse trainer Pat Rowan and already had some big wins under his belt. He began training Sherga at the Beechhurst Stables in the English town of Newmarket,
他的主人和公众，他们给他起了个绰号叫“爱尔兰的飞马”。舒尔加最迷人的特征之一是，当他全速驰骋时，他的舌头会耷拉在嘴巴的一侧，一位赛马解说员说，这让他看起来像一个正在解决棘手数学题的10岁孩子。舒尔加的驯马师是迈克尔·斯托特（Michael Stoute），他是巴巴多斯人，于1978年被阿迦汗雇佣。迈克尔被视为后起之秀，曾担任英国著名驯马师帕特·罗文（Pat Rowan）的助手，并已经取得了一些重大胜利。他开始在英国纽马克特镇的比奇赫斯特马厩训练舒尔加，
but initially saw nothing special about him, viewing him as somewhat immature. In August to 1980, jockey Leicester Pigott began taking Sherga out for morning rides and the two quickly formed a bond. Leicester was one of only two jockeys who ever rode Sherga, the other being Walter Swinburne. In racing Sherga, the two jockeys dressed in the racing colours of the Aga Khan, an emerald green cap and jacket with red epaulets. Sherga's racing career began at the Crease Plate in Newbury, on September 19, 1980, when he was two and a half years old.
但起初并未看出他有什么特别之处，认为他多少有些不够成熟。1980年8月，骑师莱斯特·皮戈特（Lester Piggott）开始带舒尔加晨练，两人很快建立起了深厚的感情。莱斯特是骑过舒尔加的仅有的两名骑师之一，另一位是沃尔特·斯温伯恩（Walter Swinburne）。在策骑舒尔加时，这两位骑师穿着阿迦汗的赛马服——饰有红色肩章的翠绿色帽子和夹克。舒尔加的赛马生涯始于1980年9月19日在纽伯里的克里斯盘子赛（Crease Plate），当时他两岁半。
He was the favourite to win at odds of 11-8 and after initially keeping behind, he ultimately won by two and a half lengths. This style of racing became his signature, with Sherga often sitting in third or fourth place until he sped up and ultimately overtook the winning horses in the final straight. In 1980 and 1981, he went on to win six of the eight major races he competed in, including the Guardian newspaper Classic Trial, Chester Vars, the Epsom Derby, the Irish Derby, and the King George VI and Queen Elizabeth Stakes. These collective wins were considered to be tremendous achievements in the racing world,
他是以11比8的赔率夺冠的热门人选，起初落在后面，最终以两个半马身的优势获胜。这种赛马风格成了他的标志，舒尔加经常保持在第三或第四位，直到他加速并在最后的直道上最终超越了获胜的马匹。在1980年和1981年，他继续赢得了他参加的八场主要比赛中的六场，其中包括《卫报》经典预赛（Guardian newspaper Classic Trial）、切斯特瓦斯赛（Chester Vase）、叶森德比（Epsom Derby）、爱尔兰德比（Irish Derby）以及乔治六世国王和伊丽莎白女王锦标赛（King George VI and Queen Elizabeth Stakes）。这些集体的胜利被认为是赛马界巨大的成就，
and as Sherga's reputation and prestige grew, so did his popularity. Horse racing enthusiast Richard Bearline described his appeal in the Guardian newspaper, writing, To say Sherga typifies the perfect racehorse would not be overstating the case. His powers of acceleration are exceptional. One or two experts have told me they consider Sherga the best horse they've ever seen. In 1981, Sherga was named European Horse of the Year and he soon became a household name in Ireland and England, even amongst those who didn't follow racing. On July 9, 1981, Diaga Khan announced he would be keeping Sherga in Ireland in order to use
随着舒尔加的声誉和威望不断增长，他的受欢迎程度也随之上升。赛马爱好者理查德·贝尔林（Richard Bearline）在《卫报》上描述了他的吸引力，他写道：“要说舒尔加是完美赛马的典型，一点也不为过。他的爆发力非常惊人。有一两位专家告诉我，他们认为舒尔加是他们见过的最好的马。”1981年，舒尔加被评为欧洲年度赛马，他很快在爱尔兰和英格兰家喻户晓，甚至在那些不关注赛马的人当中也是如此。1981年7月9日，阿迦汗宣布他将把舒尔加留在爱尔兰，以便
him as a stud. Unlike race winnings, which can be inconsistent and unpredictable, putting a racehorse to stud provides a steady income, and Diaga Khan expected to breed ten of his mares to Sherga each breeding season. Diaga Khan wanted to syndicate Sherga, which meant selling shares so that ownership of the horse would be split between several individuals. With 40 shares up for grabs, Diaga Khan revealed he would be keeping six shares and selling the remaining 34 at the price of £250,000 each, the equivalent of around one and a half
用他来配种。与可能不稳定且不可预测的赛马奖金不同，让赛马进行配种可以提供稳定的收入，阿迦汗预计每个繁殖季会让他的十匹母马与舒尔加交配。阿迦汗希望将舒尔加组建成一个辛迪加（股份公司），这意味着出售股份，以便这匹马的所有权由多个人分摊。在有40份股份可供争夺的情况下，阿迦汗透露，他将保留6份股份，并以每份25,000英镑的价格出售其余的34份股份，这相当于当今货币大约150万
million Australian dollars in today's money. Anyone who knew anything about horse racing wanted in on the action and the shares were quickly snapped up. In total, the syndicate invested £10 million in Sherga, which was a record at the time for Astalian at stud. It was reported that Diaga Khan could have made more money by shipping Sherga to the United States, where some breeding syndicates were prepared to pay up to 40 million US dollars. However, there had been a recent outbreak of a highly infectious equine venereal disease,
澳大利亚元。任何懂赛马的人都想参与其中，这些股份很快就被抢购一空。该辛迪加总共向舒尔加投资了1000万英镑，这在当时创下了澳大利亚种马场的纪录。据报道，阿迦汗本可以通过将舒尔加运往美国赚取更多的钱，在那里一些育种辛迪加准备支付高达4000万美元的费用。然而，最近爆发了一种高度传染性的马匹性病，
known as contagious sequine metritis, resulting in international travel restrictions. In addition, Diaga Khan wanted Sherga to remain in Ireland because he was so well loved by the public and provided a respite for the tension between the Republic and Northern Ireland. Owning shares in Sherga was considered to be a great privilege and it was up to each shareholder to organise their own insurance. Each of their individual policies ensured Sherga for death caused by accident, illness and disease, but only some of the policies covered theft.
被称为传染性马子宫炎（contagious equine metritis），导致了国际旅行限制。此外，阿迦汗希望舒尔加留在爱尔兰，因为他深受公众喜爱，并为共和国与北爱尔兰之间的紧张关系提供了喘息之机。拥有舒尔加的股份被认为是一种巨大的特权，每个股东都需自行安排保险。他们各自的保单都确保了舒尔加因意外、疾病和瘟疫导致的死亡，但只有部分保单涵盖了盗窃。
Trainer Michael Stout and Diaga Khan wanted to race Sherga in the October 1981 French pre-delarct detrion, also known simply as the Ark. To gain entry, Sherga first needed to succeed in a prep race, so it was decided he would compete in the St. Leger Stakes at Doncaster in England. It was the final race for the season and to the last time Sherga would race as a three-year-old. Although he was a favourite, he finished in fourth place, with his poor performance attributed to the fact that it had rained heavily the previous evening. This loss meant that racing in the Ark was out of the picture.
驯马师迈克尔·斯托特和阿迦汗希望让舒尔加参加1981年10月的法国凯旋门大赛（Prix de l'Arc de Triomphe），也就是简称为“凯旋门”（the Ark）的比赛。为了获得参赛资格，舒尔加首先需要在预赛中取得成功，因此决定让他参加在英格兰唐卡斯特举行的圣莱杰锦标赛（St. Leger Stakes）。这是本赛季的最后一场比赛，也是舒尔加最后一次以三岁马身份参赛。尽管他是夺冠热门，但他最终名列第四，其糟糕的表现被归咎于前一天晚上下了大雨这一事实。这场失利意味着参加凯旋门大赛已无可能。
Diaga Khan didn't want any further losses impacting on Sherga's desirability as a start, and it was therefore decided that he'd be retired at the peak of his short, yet illustrious racing career. To celebrate Sherga's achievements, a public celebration was held in the Irish town of Newbridge, with Diaga Khan parading Sherga in front of crowds along the main street while a pipe band played. At the time of Sherga's retirement, he was the most valuable stud horse in Ireland, making Diaga Khan the leading breeder.
阿迦汗不希望任何进一步的失利影响舒尔加作为种马的吸引力，因此决定在他短暂而辉煌的赛马生涯巅峰时期让他退役。为了庆祝舒尔加的成就，爱尔兰新桥镇（Newbridge）举行了一场公众庆典，阿迦汗带着舒尔加在大街上巡游，接受人群的欢呼，同时一支风笛乐队在演奏。在舒尔加退役时，他是爱尔兰最有价值的种马，这使阿迦汗成为了领先的育种家。
It was expected that Sherga would produce many offspring who would be equally successful racehorses. He was taken to the Balimani stud farm in Newbridge, where he was kept in a four-stalled stallion barn. Like most other horse studs in Ireland at the time, Balimani had very few security measures in place. The entrance consisted of a five-bar wooden gate that could be unlocked from the outside, and led to the stables where nameplates identified each of the horses.
人们预计舒尔加会繁育出许多同样成功的赛马后代。他被带到了新桥的巴利莫尼种马场（Balimani stud farm），在那里他被安置在一个四间马厩的种公马马厩里。就像当时爱尔兰大多数其他种马场一样，巴利莫尼的安全措施非常少。入口处由一个五档木制大门组成，可以从外面打开，通往标有每匹马名字的马厩。
The staff noted Sherga was a very agreeable horse with a good temperament. He was mainly looked after by 53-year-old horse groom Jim Fitzgerald, who lived with his wife and children down a quiet, tree-lined street a short walk from Balimani. Jim's proximity to the stud farm was intentional, as his role required him to be available to attend to the horses at any and all times. He had a lifelong love of horses, and had started working for the Aga Khan as an assistant when he was just 16. Jim took his job very seriously, and spent each day talking to the horses, immaculately
工作人员指出，舒尔加是一匹非常温顺、脾气很好的马。他主要由53岁的马夫吉姆·菲茨杰拉德（Jim Fitzgerald）照顾，吉姆和他的妻子及孩子们住在离巴利莫尼步行不远的一条安静、绿树成荫的街道上。吉姆离种马场这么近是刻意安排的，因为他的职责要求他随时随地都能照顾马匹。他对马有着终身的热爱，在16岁时就开始为阿迦汗担任助理。吉姆对工作非常认真，每天都花时间跟马说话，一丝不苟地
cleaning their stables, and grooming them thoroughly. When the 1982 breeding season arrived, Sherga was studded out at the cost of £70,000 per day, the equivalent of around $118,000 in today's money. By the end of the year, he had fathered 37 foals, and was booked to breed with 55 mares in the 1983 season, which was due to commence on February 14. One week prior, on Tuesday, February 8, a large horse auction hosted by Goff's sales took place in the village of Kil, located 22km south-west of Balimani. The auction attracted visitors from all over Ireland, with the typically quiet and peaceful
清洁它们的马厩，并彻底为它们梳洗。当1982年的繁殖季到来时，舒尔加的配种费为每天70,000英镑，相当于当今货币大约118,000美元。到年底，他已经繁育了37匹小马驹，并预定在1983年季与55匹母马配种，该季节原定于2月14日开始。一周前，即2月8日星期二，由高夫斯销售公司（Goff's Sales）主办的一场大型马匹拍卖会在基尔村（Kil）举行，该村位于巴利莫尼西南22公里处。拍卖会吸引了来自爱尔兰各地的参观者，原本安静祥和的
area becoming a hive of activity as people, traffic, and horse floats milled around well into the night. As it was also nearly the breeding season, there were a greater number of horse floats around than usual, as mares were moved to various stud farms. February 8 was one of the coldest days Ireland had experienced that year, but was otherwise a regular day for Sherga at the stud farm. In the morning, he was taken out for exercise, and later returned to his stable in the afternoon by Jim Fitzgerald.
地区变成了一个活动中心，人群、交通和马匹拖车一直晃悠到深夜。由于这也接近繁殖季节，周围的马匹拖车比平时更多，因为母马被运往各个种马场。2月8日是爱尔兰当年经历的最冷的日子之一，但对种马场的舒尔加来说，除此之外这是平常的一天。早上，他被带出去锻炼，下午晚些时候由吉姆·菲茨杰拉德带回他的马厩。
That evening, Jim went home to eat dinner with his wife Maj and their six children, the youngest of whom was five years old. At 8pm, Jim returned to the Balimani stables to check that the horses were comfortable and settled. The night was cold and foggy, but everything seemed to be in order, so Jim walked back home. At around 8.40pm, Jim was upstairs when he heard knocking at his front door, which was unusual for that time of night.
那天晚上，吉姆回家与妻子玛杰（Maj）和他们的六个孩子一起吃晚产，其中最小的孩子五岁。晚上8点，吉姆回到巴利莫尼马厩检查马匹是否舒适安顿。夜晚寒冷多雾，但一切似乎井然有序，于是吉姆步行回家。晚上8点40分左右，吉姆正在楼上，听到前门有人敲门，这在那个时间的夜晚很不寻常。
Jim headed downstairs to see who it was, but his pre-teen son Bernard had already opened the door. Standing there was a tall man dressed like the garter, the name of the Irish police service, where the balaclava pulled over his head. Given how cold it was outside, it wasn't out of the ordinary to see a garter officer wearing a balaclava. The man asked Bernard, is he in? Which Bernard took to mean his father?
吉姆下楼查看是谁，但他的预备少年儿子伯纳德（Bernard）已经把门打开了。站在那里的是一个身材高大的男子，打扮得像加达（the Garda，爱尔兰警察服务的名称），头上拉着巴拉克拉法帽（滑雪面罩）。鉴于外面天气那么冷，看到加达警官戴着巴拉克拉法帽并不稀奇。那个人问伯纳德：“他在里面吗？”伯纳德以为这是指他的父亲。
He turned to call for Jim, but as he did so, the man hit Bernard across his lower back, striking him to the ground. By the time Jim made it downstairs, the man had pinned Bernard to the floor with one hand. In the other, he held a pistol, which he pointed towards Jim. At this point, two more balaclava-clad pistol-wielding men entered the house and pointed their guns at the family. Another two assailants then burst through the door and ushered the children to a bedroom, while the other four took Jim and his wife-match to the kitchen.
他转身去叫吉姆，但就在这时，那个人击打伯纳德的下背部，把他打倒在地。等吉姆下楼时，那个人已经用一只手将伯纳德按在地上了。另一只手里，他拿着一把手枪，指着吉姆。此时，另外两个戴着巴拉克拉法帽、手持手枪的男子闯入屋里，用枪指着这家人。接着又有两名袭击者破门而入，把孩子们带到一卧室，而另外四人则将吉姆和他的妻子马奇带到厨房。
Jim noted that the men were all very calm and organised, and referred to one another using the code word Creswell. It was obvious to him that the attack had been carefully planned. One of the men told Jim they had come for Shergar, and demanded to be taken to him. They told Jim to get his code, and then marched him over to Ballymoney at gunpoint, while the other two armed men stayed at the house to keep an eye on the family. At 8.50pm, Jim and his attackers arrived at the stables. Jim believed that horses could sense the emotions of people they were familiar with, and did
吉姆注意到这些人非常冷静且有条理，他们用代号“克雷斯韦尔”（Creswell）称呼彼此。很显然，这次袭击是经过精心策划的。其中一个人告诉吉姆他们是为舒尔加而来的，并要求带他们去找他。他们让吉姆拿上他的密码，然后用枪指着他把他押到巴利莫尼，而另外两名武装人员则留在家里监视这家人。晚上8点50分，吉姆和他的袭击者到达了马厩。吉姆相信马匹能够感知熟悉的人的情绪，并
his best to stay calm so as not to alarm Shergar. It seemed to work as Shergar appeared relaxed and was easily led from his stable. Still holding Jim at gunpoint, the men then demanded that he load Shergar into a horse float that was attached to a nearby car. At this point, Jim noticed that the men were carrying shortwave radios. He also noted that one of the men seemed to have experience handling horses, as he was more confident with his movements and less wary of Shergar than the others. By 9.00pm, Jim had successfully loaded Shergar into the float.
尽最大努力保持冷静，以免惊吓到舒尔加。这似乎起作用了，舒尔加看起来很放松，很容易被牵出马厩。男子们依然用枪指着吉姆，接着要求他把舒尔加装上一辆挂在附近汽车上的马匹拖车。此时，吉姆注意到这些人带着短波无线电。他还注意到，其中一个人似乎有处理马匹的经验，因为他在移动时比其他人更有自信，对舒尔加也不那么警惕。到晚上9点，吉姆已成功将舒尔加装进拖车。
Some of the thieves then got into the car and drove away, as Jim watched helplessly. The remaining men took Jim back to his house and kept him under watch until 10pm, at which point three of them loaded him into the back of a van and drove off. Jim was ordered to lie down with a coat over his face. His captors then drove over the rough country roads at high speeds, repeatedly warning Jim that he and his family would face violent ramifications if they went to the police. After approximately two hours, they dropped Jim off at the side of a road about 48km northeast of Ballimani and gave him directions to the nearest town called Kilcock.
随后，一些小偷上了车开走了，吉姆只能无助地看着。剩下的人把吉姆带回他的家，并看守他到晚上10点，随后其中三人把他塞进一辆面包车的后备箱开车离去。吉姆被命令躺下，脸上盖着一件外套。他的劫持者随后高速驶过颠簸的乡间小路，多次警告吉姆，如果他们报警，他和他的家人将面临暴力后果。大约两个小时后，他们把吉姆扔在距离巴利莫尼东北约48公里处的一条公路旁，并告诉他去最近的基尔科克镇（Kilcock）的路线。
The thieves told Jim they wanted £2 million for Shergar's safe return and would be using the codename King Neptune for upcoming ransom negotiations. After telling Jim not to look back, they drove away into the night. Terrified, Jim walked to Kilcock, arriving just before midnight and pounded on the door of a Chinese restaurant until the owners let him in. They allowed him to use their phone and Jim called his brother Desvis Gerald, who drove out to give him a lift back to Ballimani. By the time he arrived home, the armed men had left and his family were waiting up, shaken,
小偷告诉吉姆，他们要200万英镑才肯安全归还舒尔加，并且在即将到来的勒索谈判中将使用代号“海王星国王”（King Neptune）。在告诉吉姆不要回头看后，他们驾车驶入夜色中。惊恐万分的吉姆步行前往基尔科克，在午夜前不久到达，并猛烈敲击一家中餐馆的门，直到老板让他进去。他们允许他使用电话，吉姆打电话给他的兄弟德斯·维斯杰拉德（Desvis Gerald），后者开车送他回巴利莫尼。等他回到家时，武装人员已经离开，他的家人正醒着等他，虽惊魂未定，
but unharmed. At 12.10am on Wednesday, February 9th, as Jim was trying to come to terms with what had happened, Belfast the based horse breeder's Jeremy and Judy Maxwell were awoken by a phone call. Judy answered and a male on the other line introduced himself as King Neptune, saying We've got Shergar. If you want proof, we'll send you his ear. Thinking it was a prank call, Judy somewhat facetiously asked the men to take good care
但毫发无伤。2月9日星期三凌晨12点10分，正当吉姆试图接受所发生的事情时，总部位于贝尔法斯特的马匹育种家杰里米（Jeremy）和朱迪·马克斯韦尔（Judy Maxwell）被一通电话吵醒。朱迪接了电话，电话那头的男性自称是海王星国王，说道：“我们有舒尔加。如果你想要证据，我们会把他的耳朵寄给你。”朱迪以为这是一通恶作剧电话，半开玩笑地要求他们好好照顾
of the horse. She then hung up and went back to sleep without giving the call much more thought. 20 minutes later at 12.30am, the phone rang at the BBC television office in Belfast. The employee who answered heard the voice of a well-educated sounding man with a southern Irish accent. He told the employee that Shergar had been kidnapped and the captors were only willing to negotiate with Britain's three best racing journalists, Derek Thompson, John Oakesy and Peter Campling.
这匹马。随后她挂断电话回去睡觉，没有对这通电话多加琢磨。20分钟后，即凌晨12点30分，贝尔法斯特的英国广播公司（BBC）电视办公室电话铃响了。接电话的员工听到一个口音听起来受过良好教育、带有南爱尔兰口音的男子的声音。他告诉这名员工，舒尔加被绑架了，绑架者只愿意与英国三位最佳赛马记者德里克·汤普森（Derek Thompson）、约翰·奥克斯利（John Oakesy）和彼得·坎普林（Peter Campling）谈判。
He ordered that the trio be at the Europa Hotel in central Belfast by the evening of Thursday, February 10 and said that on future calls he would identify himself as Zarkal, which was the name of another famous racehorse. Meanwhile, at Ballymanee, Jim Fitzgerald was contemplating what to do next. At 1.15am, he called his boss, Gilla Dreon, who was the stud manager for the Aga Khan's Irish studs and told him what had happened. Gilla wanted to phone the guarder, but Jim warned him not to, so Gilla called the Aga Khan in Switzerland instead.
他命令这三人在2月10日星期四晚上之前到达贝尔法斯特市中心的欧罗巴酒店（Europa Hotel），并表示在以后的电话中他会自称为“扎尔卡尔”（Zarkal），这是另一匹著名赛马的名字。与此同时，在巴利莫尼，吉姆·菲茨杰拉德正在考虑下一步该怎么做。凌晨1点15分，他打电话给他的老板吉拉·德雷昂（Gilla Dreon），后者是阿迦汗爱尔兰种马场的场长，并把发生的事情告诉了他。吉拉想打电话给加达，但吉姆警告他不要这么做，于是吉拉转而打电话给远在瑞士的阿迦汗。
Unable to get a hold of him, he then called Shergar's vet and shareholder Stan Cosgrove. The two men drove to Ballymanee to speak with Jim in person and to confirm that Shergar really had been stolen. Stan Cosgrove soon phoned his friend, Captain Sean Berry, the manager of the Irish Thurabread Breeders Association and told him what had happened. Captain Berry later told author Milton C. Toby that in his business, the telephone call from Stan Cosgrove was, quote, the equivalent of the director of the Louvre in Paris being told that the Mona Lisa had been stolen.
由于联系不上他，他又打电话给舒尔加的兽医兼股东斯坦·科斯格罗夫（Stan Cosgrove）。这两个人开车前往巴利莫尼亲自与吉姆交谈，并确认舒尔加确实被偷了。斯坦·科斯格罗夫不久后打电话给他的朋友肖恩·巴里船长（Captain Sean Berry），即爱尔兰纯血马育种协会的经理，并把发生的事告诉了他。巴里船长后来告诉作家米尔顿·C·托比（Milton C. Toby），在他的行业中，斯坦·科斯格罗夫打来的电话，引述道：“相当于巴黎卢浮宫的馆长被告知蒙娜丽莎被盗了一样。”
At 1.45am, racing journalist Derek Thompson awoke to a phone call in his London hotel room. It was a reporter from London's Press Association who advised Derek that Shergar had been kidnapped and the captors had asked to speak with him personally. Derek didn't believe this at first, but the reporter repeatedly told him that it was not a joke. Derek eventually agreed to accompany the other two racing journalists, John Oxy and Peter Campling, to Belfast the following evening to negotiate Shergar's release.
凌晨1点45分，赛马记者德里克·汤普森在伦敦酒店房间的电话铃声中醒来。那是伦敦新闻联合会（Press Association）的一名记者，他通知德里克舒尔加被绑架了，绑架者要求与他本人亲自通话。德里克起初不相信这一点，但该记者一再告诉他这不是一个玩笑。德里克最终同意第二天晚上与另外两位赛马记者约翰·奥克斯利和彼得·坎普林一起前往贝尔法斯特，以谈判释放舒尔加事宜。
By 4am, Gilla Dreon had managed to get hold of the Aga Khan in Switzerland. Gilla asked whether they should simply pay the ransom quietly without getting the police involved, but the Aga Khan instructed him to notify the guarder. He reasoned that there were too many shareholders involved with Shergar for him to make a decision on his own, and it was inevitable that the guarder and press would learn about the theft anyway. The Aga Khan also said that there was no guarantee that Shergar would be returned safely even if they paid the ransom, and that paying could set a precedent for further thefts of Irish
到了凌晨4点，吉拉·德雷昂设法联系上了远在瑞士的阿迦汗。吉拉询问他们是否应该在不惊动警方的情况下悄悄支付赎金，但阿迦汗指示他通知加达。他推断，涉及舒尔加的股东太多，他无法独自做出决定，而且加达和媒体无论如何最终都会知道这起盗窃案。阿迦汗还表示，即使他们支付了赎金，也不能保证舒尔加会安全归还，并且支付赎金可能会为未来盗窃爱尔兰
racehorses. By the time the guarder were notified, Shergar had been missing for almost 8 hours. This was enough time for the thieves to have taken him anywhere within Ireland, or even abroad. Tracking him would be especially difficult as the goth sales horse auction that was held the previous day meant there were a large number of horse floats travelling through the country. Because of the tensions between the Republic of Ireland and Northern Ireland, all the main
赛马的行为开创先例。当加达接到通知时，舒尔加已经失踪了近8个小时。这有足够的时间让小偷把他带到爱尔兰境内的任何地方，甚至带到国外。追踪他将极其困难，因为前一天举行的高夫斯销售马匹拍卖会意味着有大量的马匹拖车在全国各地穿梭。由于爱尔兰共和国与北爱尔兰之间的紧张关系，所有主要的
guarder stations had radio contact with one another. This meant that if officials had been notified earlier, stations further away could have put up roadblocks and possibly found Shergar within hours of the kidnap. Yet, by the time the kidnapping was reported, the area was too large to cover, leading many to believe that the search was doomed from the start. Chief Superintendent James Murphy was assigned to lead the case. Nicknamed the Spud, he was a tall, slim man with a strong Irish accent and a dark sense of humour, who always wore a three-piece suit with a black felt trilby hat similar to
加达警局之间都有无线电联络。这意味着，如果官方早点接到通知，更远的警局本可以设置路障，并可能在绑架后几小时内找到舒尔加。然而，等到绑架事件被报案时，搜寻范围已经太大而无法覆盖，导致许多人认为搜寻从一开始就注定要失败。总警司詹姆斯·墨菲（James Murphy）被指派领导此案。绰号“马铃薯”（the Spud）的他是一个身材高大、苗条的男子，有着浓重的爱尔兰口音和黑色幽默感，总是穿着一套三件套西装，戴着一顶类似于
a fedora. By midday, the media had gotten hold of the story and news reports of Shergar's theft were being broadcast around the world. Journalists flocked to Newbridge and the small town was soon swimming with reporters. Speaking on the steps of the Newbridge guarder station, Chief Murphy told the gathering reporters that he wasn't overly concerned about the case, because, quote, ''Astallian cannot be kept by people who are not well up in the horsey field and who do not know how to keep the animal.''
费多拉帽（fedora）的黑色呢帽（trilby hat）。到了中午，媒体已经掌握了这起新闻，舒尔加被盗的新闻报道正在世界各地广为播报。记者们蜂拥至新桥，这个小镇很快就挤满了记者。墨菲总警长在新桥加达警局的台阶上对聚集的记者们说，他并不十分担心这个案子，因为，引述道：“一匹种马是不能由那些对马术领域不熟悉、不知道如何照料动物的人所饲养的。”
He openly admitted that the police had no leads, but ordered that all Irish stud farms and stables be searched immediately. 40 detectives were sent to Newbridge to work on the case and help with the search, while the head of the guarder's murder squad was also assigned to the investigation. The International Criminal Police Organization, more commonly known as Interpol, were contacted due to the possibility that Shergar had been smuggled out of the country. It is inquired about any possible security footage, but the owners of Balimani Stud had considered installing a security system an unnecessary expense, as it didn't seem possible
他公开承认警方没有任何线索，但下令立即搜查所有爱尔兰种马场和马厩。40名侦探被派往新桥负责此案并协助搜查，加达谋杀调查组的负责人也被指派参与此项调查。国际刑警组织（通常称为“Interpol”）由于舒尔加可能被走私出境的可能性而被联系。人们询问了任何可能的安全监控录像，但巴利莫尼种马场的主人认为安装安防系统是一项不必要的开支，因为一匹赛马似乎根本不可能
that a racehorse could ever be stolen. Balimani did have one CCTV camera inside the main stable where Shergar was housed, but it was broken and didn't even have a tape inside. Several search efforts uncovered no sign of Shergar, but the guarder did find caches of IRA weapons hidden throughout the Irish countryside, which resulted in the IRA losing many of their safehouses. At 4.05 on Wednesday afternoon, one of the thieves phoned Balimani Stud. Gila Drian answered, but as he was French and not fluent in English, he struggled to
被偷。巴利莫尼在关押舒尔加的主马厩内确实有一个闭路电视摄像头，但它坏了，里面甚至连磁带都没有。数次搜查都没有发现舒尔加的踪迹，但加达确实在爱尔兰乡村各处找到了藏匿的爱尔兰共和军武器库，这导致爱尔兰共和军失去了许多安全屋。周三下午4点05分，其中一名小偷给巴利莫尼种马场打了一个电话。吉拉·德雷昂接了电话，但由于他是法国人且英语不够流利，他很难
understand the caller's demands. The caller eventually became frustrated and hung up. Just over an hour and a half later at 5.45, the thief phoned back. This time, Gila asked him to speak slowly, which he did. The caller introduced himself as King Neptune and demanded £2 million for Shergar's safe release, with the ransom to be paid in 20, 50 and 100 pound notes. He also requested a phone number in France that he and his men could contact instead of making calls to Irish landlines that could be traced.
听懂来电者的要求。来电者最终感到沮丧并挂断了电话。一个半小时多一点后的5点45分，小偷回了电话。这一次，吉拉请他慢点说，他也照做了。来电者自称是海王星国王，要求支付200万英镑以换取舒尔加的安全释放，赎金需以20、50和100英镑的面额支付。他还索要了一个法国的电话号码，以便他和他的手下可以联系，而不是拨打可能被追踪的爱尔兰座机。
Gila gave him the phone number for the Aga Khan's office in Paris. When word of the ransom demand reached Shergar's shareholders, they thought it was odd that the thieves had demanded to be paid in 100 pound notes, as such notes didn't exist. This led some of them to believe that Shergar's theft was more a publicity stunt than a genuine kidnapping for ransom. Regardless, the shareholders hired a company named Control Risks Group Limited to handle the negotiations on their behalf, and a negotiator was sent to the Aga Khan's office in Paris in anticipation of further incoming calls.
吉拉给了他阿迦汗巴黎办公室的电话号码。当赎金要求的消息传到舒尔加的股东耳中时，他们觉得小偷要求以100英镑的面额支付很奇怪，因为这种面额根本不存在。这让其中一些人认为，舒尔加被偷更像是一场宣传噱头，而不是真正的绑架勒索。不管怎样，股东们聘请了一家名为“控险集团有限公司”（Control Risks Group Limited）的公司代表他们处理谈判，一名谈判代表被派往阿迦汗的巴黎办公室，以防接听更多来电。
The following day of Thursday, February 10, racing journalists Derek Thompson, John Oxy and Peter Campling were taken to Belfast's Europa Hotel as the thieves had requested. At the time, the hotel was informally used as a home base for foreign journalists, which coupled with its central location, had made it the ideal target for bombings by the IRA. The building had earned the undesirable reputation of being the most bombed hotel in Europe, a fact that made the three journalists wary as they entered its lobby. Other reporters who had caught wind of the story had already gathered outside the building. Within minutes of their arrival, a message over the loudspeaker announced that there
第二天，即2月10日星期四，赛马记者德里克·汤普森、约翰·奥克斯利和彼得·坎普林应小偷的要求被带到贝尔法斯特的欧罗巴酒店。当时，这家酒店非正式地被用作外国记者的据点，再加上其中心位置，使其成为爱尔兰共和军炸弹袭击的理想目标。这座建筑赢得了“欧洲被炸次数最多的酒店”这一令人不快的美誉，当这三名记者走进大厅时，这一事实让他们心生警惕。听到风声的其他记者已经聚集在建筑外面。他们到达几分钟后，扩音器里传出一个消息，宣布
was a call for Derek Thompson. Derek took the phone, and the caller on the other line told him he was being watched. He was then instructed to go to the farmhouse owned by horse breeders Jeremy and Judy Maxwell, and a couple who had received a phone call from King Neptune in the early hours after Shergaugh was stolen, saying that Shergaugh had been kidnapped and that his ear could be sent as proof. The Maxwell's farmhouse was located 48km south of Belfast in the town of Downpatrick. After hanging up the phone, Derek immediately updated the guarder and the Europa Hotel's
有德里克·汤普森的电话。德里克接了电话，电话那头的人告诉他自己正在被人监视。随后他被指示前往由马匹育种家杰里米和朱迪·马克斯韦尔夫妇拥有的农舍，这对夫妇在舒尔加被偷后的凌晨曾接到自称海王星国王的电话，称舒尔加已被绑架，并称可以寄出他的耳朵作为证据。马克斯韦尔夫妇的农舍位于贝尔法斯特以南48公里的唐帕特里克镇（Downpatrick）。挂断电话后，德里克立即将最新情况通报给加达和欧罗巴酒店的
chief of security, as well as his fellow reporters John Oakesy and Peter Camping. The three racing reporters discussed how they could leave the building without being noticed to prevent the other journalists from following and possibly compromising Shergaugh's safety. Eventually, they snuck out via the hotel's kitchen and into a waiting car. When they arrived at the farmhouse, the guarder were already on site. Judy Maxwell advised that she had just received another phone call from the thieves, who this time changed the code name to Wackbalko, referencing another well-known racehorse. They had also reduced the ransom to just £40,000, equaling £1,000 for each share in Shergaugh.
保安主管，以及他的同行记者约翰·奥克斯利和彼得·坎普林。这三位赛马记者讨论了他们如何才能在不被人注意的情况下离开大楼，以防止其他记者尾随并可能危及舒尔加的安全。最终，他们从酒店厨房溜出去，上了一辆等候着的汽车。当他们到达农舍时，加达已经在现场了。朱迪·马克斯韦尔告知，她刚刚接到小偷的另一个电话，这次他们将代号更改为了“瓦克巴尔科”（Wackbalko），指的是另一匹知名的赛马。他们还将赎金降至仅40,000英镑，相当于舒尔加每股1,000英镑。
At 8.30pm, the phone rang at the Maxwell farmhouse and Derek Thompson answered it. The caller used the code word Wackbalko and repeated the £40,000 ransom demand he had given to Judy earlier. He ordered that the demands be broadcast over the BBC Evening News before abruptly hanging up, leaving the guarder within sufficient time to trace the call. Captain Sean Berry, who had been contacted by Vette Stan Cosgrove in the early hours following Shergaugh's kidnapping, was eager to help in any way he could. He contacted the members of his organisation, the Irish Thurabread Breeders Association,
晚上8点30分，马克斯韦尔农舍的电话铃响了，德里克·汤普森接了电话。来电者使用了代号“瓦克巴尔科”，并重复了早些时候告诉朱迪的40,000英镑赎金要求。他命令将这些要求在BBC晚间新闻中广播，然后突然挂断了电话，这使得加达没有足够的时间来追踪电话来源。肖恩·巴里船长在舒尔加被绑架后的凌晨曾接到兽医斯坦·科斯格罗夫的联系，他急于尽自己所能提供帮助。他联系了他所在的组织——爱尔兰纯血马育种协会的成员，
and they agreed to sponsor a reward of £50,000 for Shergaugh's safe return. The reward was advertised in Irish newspapers, alongside a phone number for the office of the Irish Act Wine Centre, which the public could call with any information. Captain Berry said his organisation was prepared to pay a higher reward if necessary, although he didn't publicise a specific amount, stating, Our association represents all horse breeders, and we decided on this course of action as a gesture on behalf of the entire breeding industry. It is vital that Shergaugh be found safe and well.
他们同意赞助50,000英镑的悬赏金，以换取舒尔加的安全归还。悬赏金刊登在爱尔兰报纸上，并附有爱尔兰葡萄酒中心（Irish Act Wine Centre）办公室的电话号码，公众可以拨打该号码提供任何信息。巴里船长表示，如有必要，他的组织准备支付更高的悬赏金，尽管他没有公布具体的金额，并声明：“我们的协会代表了所有的马匹育种者，我们决定采取这一行动，作为代表整个育种行业的一个姿态。找到舒尔加并确保他安全无恙是至关重要的。”
The guarder agreed to Captain Berry's plan on the condition that they were allowed to tap the phones in his home and office in case someone decided to contact him there instead. Within hours of the reward being publicised, calls started to come through. Some were from animal lovers concerned about Shergaugh's welfare, with one caller asking if specific information on how to feed and care for Shergaugh could be published in a local newspaper. In response, Captain Berry organised for a veterinarian to appear on Irish television to provide detailed care instructions directed at Shergaugh's captors.
加达同意了巴里船长的计划，条件是允许他们窃听他家里和办公室的电话，以防有人决定在那里联系他。悬赏金公布后的几个小时内，电话开始打进来。有些是关心舒尔加福利的动物爱好者，其中一个来电者询问是否可以在当地报纸上发表关于如何喂养和照顾舒尔加的具体信息。作为回应，巴里船长安排了一位兽医出现在爱尔兰电视上，提供针对舒尔加绑架者的详细护理说明。
In addition to these well-meaning calls, Captain Berry received several threats, with one caller threatening to burn his house down if he continued to search for Shergaugh. These calls were usually terminated quickly after Captain Berry told the caller that the phones were being recorded by the guarder. Chief Superintendent James Murphy continued to provide updates to the media from the steps of the Newbridge guarder station. Due to his dark sense of humour and the vague answers he gave, many members of the press believed he wasn't taking the crime seriously.
除了这些善意的电话外，巴里船长还接到几次威胁，其中一个来电者威胁说，如果他继续寻找舒尔加，就要烧毁他的房子。在巴里船长告诉来电者电话正在被加达录音后，这些电话通常很快就会被挂断。总警司詹姆斯·墨菲继续在新桥加达警局的台阶上向媒体提供最新消息。由于他带有黑色幽默感和含糊不清的回答，许多媒体成员认为他并没有认真对待这起犯罪。
The truth was that Chief Murphy knew more about the case than he let on, and simply chose not to share the information with the media. But his secrecy added to the speculation that he didn't know what he was doing. The press dubbed him Inspector O'Cluso after the bumbling detective from the Pink Panther movies, and some reporters turned up to press conferences wearing a similar hat to his trademark Trilby as a way of poking fun at him. At 1.15am on the morning of Friday, February 11, the phone rang at the Maxwell's farmhouse in Downpatrick.
事实是，墨菲总警长对这个案子的了解比他透露的要多，只是选择不与媒体分享这些信息。但他的保密性加剧了人们对他不知所措的猜测。媒体戏称他为“克鲁索督察”（Inspector Clouseau，源自《粉红豹》电影中的笨拙侦探），一些记者甚至戴着类似于他标志性呢帽的帽子出席新闻发布会，以此来取笑他。2月11日星期五上午1点15分，唐帕特里克的马克斯韦尔农舍电话铃响了。
It was answered by journalist Derek Thompson, who was still there with the guarder. The caller introduced himself as King Neptune, and told Derek that if he didn't come up with the £40,000 ransom money by 9am, Sherga would be shot. Derek had been advised by the guarder to try and keep the caller on the line for as long as possible so they could trace the call, and he managed to drag out the conversation for roughly three minutes. This should have been enough time to trace it, but when Derek hung up, he was told that the officer responsible for tracing calls had finished his shift at midnight, leaving
接电话的是记者德里克·汤普森，他当时仍与加达在一起。来电者自称是海王星国王，并告诉德里克，如果他在上午9点之前没有凑齐40,000英镑的赎金，舒尔加就会被枪杀。加达曾建议德里克尽量让来电者在线时间长一些，以便他们追踪电话来源，他设法将谈话拖延了大约三分钟。这本该有足够的时间来追踪，但当德里克挂断电话时，他被告知负责追踪电话的警官在午夜结束了值班，留下了
nobody to fill his role. This error would turn out to be one of the biggest mistakes the guarder made during their investigation, and they received considerable backlash as a result. Six hours later, at 7am, the phone rang once more at the Maxwell's farmhouse, and Derek answered yet again. This time, the caller said that there had been an accident and Sherga was now dead. When asked where his body could be recovered from, the caller hung up. The guarder had been theorising whether two different groups had been making the ransom
没有人能填补他的空缺。事实证明，这一失误是警方在调查期间犯下的最大错误之一，他们因此受到了严厉的指责。六小时后，即早上7点，麦克斯韦家的农舍里电话再次响起，德里克又一次接起了电话。这一次，来电者说发生了一起事故，谢加现在已经死了。当被问及从哪里可以找回他的尸体时，来电者挂断了电话。警方一直在推测是否有两拨不同的人在打赎金
calls. They suspected those made to the Aga Khan's office in Paris were legitimate, while the calls to the Maxwell's and to the journalists were intentional hoaxes, designed to confuse the situation and buy time for further negotiations and more media attention. This latest call strengthened their theory, and the £40,000 ransom demand and news of Sherga's death were considered to be false. In a press conference, Chief Murphy told reporters that he was regretfully no closer to solving the case than he had been the previous day.
电话。他们怀疑打给巴黎阿迦汗办公室的电话是真的，而打给麦克斯韦家和记者的电话则是蓄意的恶作剧，旨在搞混局势，为进一步的谈判和争取更多的媒体关注争取时间。最近的这一通电话加强了他们的理论，4万英镑的赎金要求和谢加死讯的消息被认为是假的。在一次新闻发布会上，墨菲局长告诉记者，遗憾的是，他离破案并不比前一天更近一步。
Horsegroom Jim Fitzgerald was still reluctant to speak to the police. At first, he had been in such a state of shock that he was unable to recall any of the details of the attack. But by this point, he was simply fearful of the threats that thieves had made against his family. Although Chief Murphy didn't push him to speak, Jim did have one message for Sherga's captors. He asked them to feed Sherga some carrots as they were his favourite food and would
马夫吉姆·菲茨杰拉德仍然不愿意跟警方说话。起初，他处于极度震惊的状态，无法回忆起袭击的任何细节。但到了这个时候，他只是害怕小偷对他的家人发出的威胁。尽管墨菲局长没有逼他开口，但吉姆确实给谢加的绑架者带去了一条信息。他要求他们喂谢加一些胡萝卜，因为胡萝卜是他最喜欢的食物，能让他
cheer him up. At 9 o'clock that evening, another call was placed to the Aga Khan's office in Paris. The caller demanded the £2 million ransom again, but the negotiator said he didn't have the money because there were 35 shareholders he had to consult with. The negotiator also asked for proof that Sherga was still alive, which the caller agreed to provide before ordering that the money be ready by 9 the following night or Sherga would be killed. One hour later, at 10pm, another call came through to the Paris office.
高兴起来。那天晚上9点，巴黎的阿迦汗办公室又接到了一个电话。来电者再次索要200万英镑的赎金，但谈判代表称他没有这笔钱，因为有35位股东需要他去协商。谈判代表还要求提供谢加仍然活着的证据，来电者对此表示同意，随后命令必须在第二天晚上9点之前准备好钱，否则谢加就会被杀死。一小时后，即晚上10点，巴黎办公室又接到了一通电话。
By this point, the media were reporting on the claim that Sherga had been shot, made during the phone call to the Maxwell's house that morning. The caller told the negotiator that the news was false and that he could prove Sherga was alive. He gave instructions that someone who wasn't associated with the Balimani start needed to travel to the Crofton Airport Hotel in Dublin. Once they arrived at the hotel reception, they were to use the alias Johnny Logan, the name of a famous Irish pop singer, at which point they would receive proof that Sherga
此时，媒体正在报道那天早上打到麦克斯韦家的电话中所声称的谢加被枪击的消息。来电者告诉谈判代表，这个消息是假的，他可以证明谢加还活着。他给出了指示：一个与巴利马尼无关的人需要前往都柏林的克罗夫顿机场酒店。一旦他们到达酒店前台，他们就要使用约翰尼·洛根这个化名（这是一个著名的爱尔兰流行歌手的名字），届时他们将收到谢加
was still alive. The caller warned the negotiator not to tell the guarder about this plan. Ignoring the thieves' request to send someone who wasn't associated with Balimani, the owner's syndicate chose Sherga's vet, Stan Cosgrove, to attend the Crofton Airport Hotel. They also tipped off the guarder, who sent special armed officers to surround the premises. At 9 o'clock, on the morning of Saturday, February 12, Stan arrived at the hotel and asked, Have you got a message here for Johnny Logan? The staff at reception said, No.
仍然活着的证据。来电者警告谈判代表不要将这个计划告诉警方。马场主人的辛迪加没有理会小偷要求派一个与巴利马尼无关的人的要求，而是选择让谢加的兽医斯坦·科斯格罗夫前往克罗夫顿机场酒店。他们还向警方通风报信，警方派出了特种武装警察包围了酒店。2月12日星期六上午9点，斯坦到达酒店并问道：“这里有给约翰尼·洛根的留言吗？”前台的工作人员说：“没有。”
Unsure of what to do next, Stan ate breakfast at the hotel while waiting for further news. At 11.15am, one of the thieves called the Aga Khan's office in Paris, Furious. They had been unable to deliver the proof of life to the Crofton Airport Hotel because the building was surrounded by police officers. The caller threatened to kill Sherga as well as the negotiator if they were caught by the guarder. Four hours later, at 3.12pm, the thieves phoned Paris once again. They accused the negotiator of stalling for time and said he had one hour to get the £2
斯坦不知道接下来该怎么办，便在酒店吃了早餐，等待进一步的消息。上午11点15分，其中一名小偷愤怒地打电话给巴黎的阿迦汗办公室。他们无法将活着的证据送到克罗夫顿机场酒店，因为大楼被警察包围了。来电者威胁说，如果他们被警方抓到，就要杀死谢加和谈判代表。四个小时后，即下午3点12分，小偷再次给巴黎打电话。他们指责谈判代表拖延时间，并表示他有一个小时的时间凑齐200
million ransom together or Sherga would be killed. When the negotiator said the shareholders were concerned that Sherga was already dead, he was told that proof of life could be found at the Rossnery Hotel in the town of Drohada, 49km north of Dublin. A guarder officer went to the Rossnery Hotel reception, where he was given a polaroid photo. It was a close-up shot of the horse's head, taken next to a copy of the Irish news newspaper, dated the previous day of February 11, 1983. Vet Stan Cosgrove was called to the Newbridge guarder station to examine the photograph.
万英镑的赎金，否则谢加就会被杀。当谈判代表说股东们担心谢加已经死了时，对方告诉他，可以在都柏林以北49公里处的德罗海达镇的罗斯内里酒店找到活着的证据。一名警官来到罗斯内里酒店前台，在那里他拿到了一张宝丽来照片。这是一张马头的特写镜头，拍摄于一份日期为前一天（即1983年2月11日）的《爱尔兰新闻》报纸旁。兽医斯坦·科斯格罗夫被叫到纽布里奇警察局检查这张照片。
He was certain the horse in the picture was Sherga, but as it didn't show the horse's body, he couldn't tell for sure whether or not it proved that Sherga was still alive. Furthermore, as the newspaper was from the day prior, it was possible that Sherga had been killed after the photo was taken. Details of the photo were withheld from the press, with the guarder denying that any such polaroid existed. At 5pm, the thieves once again called the Agakhan's Paris office demanding that the ransom be paid.
他确信照片里的马是谢加，但由于它没有拍到马的身体，他无法确定这是否能证明谢加还活着。此外，由于报纸是前一天的，谢加有可能是在照片拍完后被杀害的。照片的细节对新闻界保密，警方否认存在任何此类宝丽来照片。下午5点，小偷再次打电话给阿迦汗的巴黎办公室，要求支付赎金。
The negotiator said the shareholders wanted to see a full-bodied photo of Sherga standing up to prove he was still alive. This angered the caller, leading him to threaten, quote, You may not pay for this horse, but you will definitely pay for the next one when you see what we do to this horse, before hanging up. The Agakhan still wanted to buy more time, as it was against his principles to give in and pay the ransom. The Irish and British governments agreed with his decision to withhold payment, confirming
谈判代表说，股东们想看一张谢加站立着的全身照，以证明他还活着。这惹怒了来电者，导致他威胁道：“你们可能不会为这匹马付钱，但当你们看到我们对这匹马做的事情时，你们肯定会为下一匹马付钱，”随后便挂断了电话。阿迦汗仍然想争取更多的时间，因为妥协并支付赎金违背了他的原则。爱尔兰和英国政府同意他拒绝支付赎金的决定，确认
that under no circumstances would they assist with facilitating the money. Five and a half hours later, at 10.40pm, the thieves called the Paris office to yet again ask for the ransom. The negotiator repeated the shareholders' demand for further proof of life, to which the caller replied, If you're not satisfied, that's it. Then promptly hung up. Days passed without any further contact from the thieves or any developments in the case.
在任何情况下都不会协助提供这笔资金。五个半小时后，即晚上10点40分，小偷打通了巴黎办公室的电话，再次索要赎金。谈判代表重申了股东们要求提供进一步生存证据的要求，对此来电者回答说：“如果你不满意，那就这样吧。”然后迅速挂断了电话。数日过去，小偷再也没有联系过他们，案情也没有任何进展。
On Tuesday, February 15, one week after Sherga was stolen, a man named Paddy McCann was walking through County Tyrone in Northern Ireland when he came across a horse's dismembered hind leg that had been crudely severed at the hip joint. Paddy was a horse enthusiast and could tell by looking at the limb that it belonged to a thoroughbred that had been wearing professionally shod horse shoes. He immediately thought of Sherga and reported the discovery to police. Authorities seized the leg, but as it didn't have white sock markings on its hoof like all four of Sherga's limbs did, it was confirmed not to be his.
2月15日星期二，即谢加被盗一周后，一个名叫帕迪·麦坎的人正走在北爱尔兰的蒂龙郡，当时他偶然发现了一匹马被肢解的后腿，这条腿在髋关节处被粗暴地切断了。帕迪是个养马爱好者，他一看这条腿就知道它属于一匹曾经穿戴过专业钉制马蹄铁的纯种马。他立刻想到了谢加，并向警方报告了这一发现。当局没收了这条腿，但由于它不像谢加的四肢那样蹄子上带有白色的袜子斑纹，因此被证实不是它的。
That same day, the guarder released a description of three of the suspects. Although Jim Fitzgerald hadn't seen their faces due to the balaclavas they'd been wearing, the groom at Ballimani had witnessed some men hanging around the stud farm's entrance and was able to provide further information on their facial features. One of the suspects was labelled as a jockey type, being five foot three inches tall and having a slight build. He was aged in his mid-twenties with a dark complexion, hair combed down across his forehead, and was wearing jeans and a denim jacket.
就在同一天，警方发布了其中三名嫌疑人的特征描述。尽管吉姆·菲茨杰拉德因为他们戴着巴拉克拉法帽而没有看到他们的脸，但巴利马尼的马夫曾看到一些人在种马场入口附近闲逛，并能够提供关于他们面部特征的更多信息。其中一名嫌疑人被称为“骑师型”，身高五英尺三英寸（约160厘米），身材瘦小。他二十岁出头，肤色较深，头发梳向额头，穿着牛仔裤和牛仔夹克。
Based on this description, some journalists surmised that he may have previously worked with Sherga at the stud farm, adding to Jim Fitzgerald's theory that one of the thieves had appeared proficient at handling horses. The second suspect was in his early twenties, was five foot seven inches tall and had a medium build. He had dark hair parted to the left, a large, prominent nose, and was wearing a brown jacket. The third suspect was five foot eight, of medium build and undetermined age, and had been wearing a dark jacket and pants with a hat that had a shiny peak.
根据这一描述，一些记者推测他可能以前在种马场和谢加一起工作过，这印证了吉姆·菲茨杰拉德的理论，即其中一名小偷表现得很擅长处理马匹。第二名嫌疑人二十岁出头，身高五英尺七英寸（约170厘米），中等身材。他留着向左分叉的深色头发，鼻子又大又显眼，穿着棕色夹克。第三名嫌疑人身高五英尺八英寸（约173厘米），中等身材，年龄不详，穿着深色夹克和裤子，戴着一顶有闪亮帽檐的帽子。
He was described as resembling a guarder officer or bus driver. Based on these descriptions, the press referred to the three suspects as the jockey, the nose, and the guard. The guarder technical bureau used the descriptions to create photo feed images of the suspects. Although they were only intended for use by the guarder, two of the three photos were leaked to the media, with one published in the Irish independent newspaper. When a reporter asked Chief Murphy whether the release of the images had resulted in any clues, he responded,
据描述，他长得像一名警官或公交车司机。根据这些描述，媒体将这三名嫌疑人称为“骑师”、“鼻子”和“卫兵”。警方技术局利用这些描述制作了嫌疑人的面部合成图。尽管这些照片本意仅供警方使用，但其中两张照片泄露给了媒体，一张发表在《爱尔兰独立报》上。当一名记者问墨菲局长发布这些照片是否带来了任何线索时，他回答说：
We have got a good description, but what we haven't got is a clue. Journalists used this quote repeatedly to highlight how botched the investigation was. As part of their investigations, the guarder followed up on a two-way radio call that had been intercepted on Sunday, February 6, two days before sugar was stolen. The call had taken place between four men in County Goreway on the west coast of the Republic of Ireland. One of the men spoke with a cultured English accent, while the other three spoke with Irish accents.
“我们得到了很好的描述，但我们没有的是线索。”记者们反复使用这句话来强调这次调查是多么的拙劣。作为调查的一部分，警方跟进了一通双向无线电通话，该通话于2月6日星期日（即糖被盗两天前）被拦截。这通通话发生在爱尔兰共和国西海岸戈尔韦郡的四名男子之间。其中一名男子带着精致的英国口音，而另外三名男子带着爱尔兰口音。
They used short phrases as though they were speaking in code and mentioned an orange car and a road that was bad for a box, presumably meaning a horse float. Suspecting the call might have had something to do with the plans to transport sugar, the guarder conducted a thorough search of County Goreway, but to no avail. On Wednesday, February 16, the guarder released a witness description of a horse float that was spotted leaving the Balimany Stard at 8.30pm on the night of sugar's disappearance. It was described as either a light blue or light green two-horse trailer that was possibly manufactured by a company called Rice.
他们使用简短的短语，就像在使用密码交谈一样，并提到了橙色汽车和一条不适合运马车的路，大概意思是指运马拖车。由于怀疑这通电话可能与运送糖的计划有关，警方对戈尔韦郡进行了彻底搜查，但无济于事。2月16日星期三，警方公布了一名目击者的描述，内容是一辆运马拖车，在糖失踪当晚8点30分被发现离开巴利马尼牧场。据描述，这是一辆浅蓝色或浅绿色的双马拖车，可能是由一家名为“赖斯”的公司制造的。
It was in rough condition, with no license plate or working lights, and was being towed by either a brown hillman hunter or a voxel. During the release of this information, investigators were optimistic that the float would be identified, but their hopes were quashed when no leads arose. Later that day, Chief Murphy stepped down from handling the press briefings, instead assigning the task to Superintendent Noel Anderson, an experienced spokesperson and senior press officer. Although he never confirmed why, it was likely that Chief Murphy stepped down due to the
它状况恶劣，没有车牌或正常工作的车灯，由一辆棕色的希尔曼猎人或沃克斯豪尔汽车拖着。在发布这些信息期间，调查人员对能够识别出这辆拖车持乐观态度，但当没有任何线索出现时，他们的希望破灭了。那天晚些时候，墨菲局长卸任了新闻发布工作，转而将这项任务交给了资深发言人和高级新闻官诺埃尔·安德森总警司。尽管他从未证实原因，但墨菲局长卸任很可能是因为
media's constant ridicule. On Saturday, February 19, a loaded magazine cartridge from an automatic rifle was found near the entrance of Balimany Stard. It was from a Steyr Daimler Pook, an Austrian submachine gun that was rare in Ireland but known to be used by the Southern Command Branch of the IRA. The guarder were unable to lift any fingerprints off the magazine or link it to an owner, and ultimately decided to withhold the discovery from the public. The days continued to pass without any further contact from Shergar's captors.
媒体的不断嘲讽。2月19日星期星期六，在巴利马尼牧场入口附近发现了一个自动步枪的装满子弹的弹匣。它来自斯太尔-戴姆勒-普赫，这是一种在爱尔兰罕见但在爱尔兰共和军南部司令部使用的奥地利冲锋枪。警方无法从弹匣上提取任何指纹，也无法将其与某个所有者联系起来，最终决定向公众隐瞒这一发现。日子一天天过去，谢加的绑架者再也没有联系过他们。
Later shareholders tried to re-establish communication with the thieves via the media, but their attempts were unsuccessful. They believed that Shergar would eventually be released unharmed, as they couldn't imagine that a fellow Irishman would kill an innocent horse and beloved national treasure. However, weeks went by without any leads or breakthroughs in the case, and the investigation and media reports started slowing down. The public were eager to help, with 150,000 people joining the search to check fields, farms and stables.
后来股东们试图通过媒体重新与小偷建立联系，但他们的尝试没有成功。他们相信谢加最终会被无罪释放，因为他们无法想象同胞会杀死一匹无辜的马和深受爱国喜爱的国家宝藏。然而，几周过去了，案件没有任何线索或突破，调查和媒体报道开始放缓。公众渴望提供帮助，有15万人加入搜寻队伍，检查田地、农场和马厩。
The guarder followed every tip-off they received, searching canal banks, travellers caravans and properties, only to find out that several of the tip-offs were hoaxes, crafted by vengeful neighbours. In a bid to gather information, detectives interviewed more than 100 jockeys from Ireland and England, with the guarder clarifying that these interviews had nothing to do with one of the suspects being described as a jockey. From an economic point of view, the theft of Shergar was a huge problem for Ireland. Not only did the horse racing industry provide 20,000 jobs within the country, but it also
警方跟进他们收到的每一条线索，搜查运河岸边、旅行者的房车和房产，结果发现几条线索都是由记仇的邻居精心策划的恶作剧。为了搜集信息，侦探们采访了来自爱尔兰和英国的100多名骑师，警方澄清说，这些采访与其中一名嫌疑人被描述为骑师没有任何关系。从经济角度来看，偷窃谢加对爱尔兰来说是一个巨大问题。赛马行业不仅在全国提供了20,000个就业岗位，而且还
generated lots of money from international sources. With the crime casting doubt on the safety of the industry, the Irish economy was at risk of impact. Chief Murphy told the press, quote, If any harm happens to that horse, it is going to do the industry an amount of anguish in this country, and for that reason alone, I would ask the kidnappers to return the horse safely. As the guarder grew increasingly desperate, they sought the help of around 50 clairvoyance,
从国际渠道产生了大量资金。由于这起犯罪给该行业的安全性打上了问号，爱尔兰经济面临着受到冲击的风险。墨菲局长对记者说：“如果那匹马受到任何伤害，将给这个国家的这个行业带来巨大的痛苦，仅凭这个原因，我就要请求绑架者安全归还这匹马。”随着警方越来越绝望，他们寻求了大约50名千里眼（通灵者）的帮助，
which drew further ridicule from the press. A majority of the psychics believed that Shergar would be found west of the River Shannon in County Goreway, which investigators believed was too compelling to ignore. They searched this area with the help of several psychics, but nothing was found. In early March, a man named Patrick Kelly recognized the description of the horse float used in Shergar's kidnapping as his own float that was stolen in County Louth, near the border of Northern Ireland. He provided photos of the float, and Jim Fitzgerald positively identified it as the one used by
这招致了媒体更多的嘲笑。大多数通灵者认为，谢加将在戈尔韦郡香农河以西被找到，调查人员认为这太具有吸引力而无法忽视。他们在几名通灵者的帮助下搜查了这个地区，但什么也没找到。3月初，一个名叫帕特里克·凯利的人认出了谢加绑架案中使用的运马拖车的描述，正是他在北爱尔兰边境附近的劳斯郡被盗的拖车。他提供了拖车的照片，吉姆·菲茨杰拉德正面确认这就是
the thieves to transport Shergar. What seemed like a big breakthrough ultimately led nowhere, as Patrick Kelly was unable to provide any further insight into who might have stolen the float. The hotline that had been set up by Captain Sean Berry, manager of the Irish Tharebred Breeders Association, remained active, and on March 16, he received a call from a man with a cultured Irish accent who requested a £250,000 reward to begin negotiations for Shergar's safe return. Captain Berry agreed to get the money together, and the caller said he would be in touch again
小偷用来运送谢加的那辆。看似重大的突破最终毫无结果，因为帕特里克·凯利无法提供关于谁可能偷了这辆拖车的任何进一步见解。爱尔兰纯种马育马者协会经理肖恩·贝里队长设立的热线电话保持畅通，3月16日，他接到了一名带有精致爱尔兰口音的男子的电话，该男子要求25万英镑的赏金，以开始就谢加的安全返回进行谈判。贝里队长同意凑齐这笔钱，来电者表示他会
soon, using the code name Rugby. This code name concerned Captain Berry, as he was a huge Rugby fan, and became paranoid that the caller may have been monitoring his personal life or watching his family. He notified the guarder, and on March 24, Rugby called again. Captain Berry told him the reward money would only be paid if he received conclusive evidence that Shergar was still alive, to which Rugby said he would be in touch. Captain Berry and his wife were scheduled to depart for a two-week holiday in the Canary Islands, but they told the guarder they'd be happy to cancel the trip in order to stay
很快再次联系，并使用代号“橄榄球”。这个代号让贝里队长感到担忧，因为他是一个巨大的橄榄球迷，并变得偏执起来，认为来电者可能在监视他的个人生活或盯着他的家人。他通知了警方，3月24日，“橄榄球”再次打来电话。贝里队长告诉他，只有在收到谢加仍然活着的决定性证据时，才会支付悬赏金，“橄榄球”对此表示他会联系的。贝里队长和他的妻子原定于前往加那利群岛进行为期两周的假期，但他们告诉警方，他们很乐意取消这次旅行以留在
home to continue negotiations. The guarder urged the couple to carry on with their plans, and while they were on holiday, no further calls came through. This added to Captain Berry's suspicion that he was under surveillance. The next phone call from Rugby came on the morning of May 2, 1983. This time he directed Captain Berry to drive to the Cadeen Hotel in Newbridge, near Balimani Dutt, to wait for an incoming phone call for a Mr Davies. Captain Berry did as he was told, with undercover guarder officers also positioning themselves
家里继续谈判。警方敦促这对夫妇继续他们的计划，在他们度假期间，没有再接到任何电话。这加剧了贝里队长认为自己被监视的怀疑。下一次来自“橄榄球”的电话是在1983年5月2日上午。这一次，他指示贝里队长开车前往巴利马尼达特附近的纽布里奇卡丁酒店，等待一个打给戴维斯先生的来电。贝里队长照做了，便衣警察也部署在
inside the hotel. At 11am, the phone rang for Mr Davies, and Captain Berry answered as directed. Rugby instructed him to return to the hotel the following afternoon, with £250,000 in cash, at which point he would be taken to see Shergar. Captain Berry went home and obtained a blood testing kit from a local Lekwine DNA testing facility. He returned to the hotel on the afternoon of May 3, where the phone rang at approximately two o'clock.
酒店内部。上午11点，打给戴维斯先生的电话响了，贝里队长按照指示接了电话。“橄榄球”指示他带着25万英镑现金在第二天下午返回酒店，届时他将被带去见谢加。贝里队长回家从当地的莱克温DNA检测机构拿到了一个血液检测试剂盒。他于5月3日下午返回酒店，大约两点钟电话响了。
This time, Rugby advised Captain Berry to travel to a payphone in Kildare at 9pm on May 5, where arrangements would be made to take him to Shergar. Undercover officers noted a man who had also been at the hotel the day prior, was watching Captain Berry closely, which confirmed their suspicion that he was under surveillance. They warned him to cease the negotiations if he feared his family was in danger, but Captain Berry wanted to persevere in the hopes of Shergar's return. At 8.57pm on May 5, he went to the phone booth in Kildare and waited for the call. Rugby rang one hour later, asking Captain Berry if he would be willing to be held with
这一次，“橄榄球”建议贝里队长在5月5日晚上9点前往基尔代尔的一个公用电话亭，届时将做出安排带他去见谢加。便衣警官注意到一名昨天也在酒店的男子正在密切监视贝里队长，这证实了他们认为他受到监视的怀疑。他们警告他，如果他担心家人处于危险之中，就停止谈判，但贝里队长希望坚持下去，以期谢加能回来。5月5日晚上8点57分，他去了基尔代尔的电话亭，等待电话。一小时后，“橄榄球”打来电话，询问贝里队长是否愿意在确认
Shergar while positive identification was made and the reward money was handed over. Captain Berry agreed, but said that vet Stan Cosgrove would have to accompany him to facilitate the necessary identity testing. Rugby said he would check and call back shortly, but Captain Berry waited and waited, and no further calls came through. He never heard from Rugby again, and the reward remained unclaimed. Shortly after this, a member of the guarder named Officer Keirnians contacted Stan Cosgrove wanting to introduce him to Dennis Manoog, a well-known horse dealer with an interesting
身份并交出悬赏金的同时与谢加关押在一起。贝里队长同意了，但表示兽医斯坦·科斯格罗夫必须陪同他以便进行必要的身份测试。“橄榄球”说他会查看并很快回电，但贝里队长等了又等，再也没有电话打进来。他再也没有听到“橄榄球”的消息，悬赏金也无人认领。此后不久，一名叫基尔尼恩斯的警官联系了斯坦·科斯格罗夫，想把他介绍给丹尼斯·马努格，一个有着有趣故事的知名马匹经销商
story to tell. Dennis told Stan that intermediaries of Shergar's captors had shown him a photo of Shergar, then placed a hood over his head and drove him to an unknown location in the Irish countryside, where he saw Shergar alive. Stan asked Dennis if £80,000 would be enough to have Shergar returned safely with no questions asked. Dennis agreed to speak to the intermediaries, who in turn agreed to the deal. Through Dennis, the thieves directed Stan to place £80,000 cash into the boot of Dennis's
要讲。丹尼斯告诉斯坦，谢加绑架者的中间人给他看了一张谢加的照片，然后把一个头套套在他头上，把他带到爱尔兰乡村的一个未知地点，在那里他看到了活着的谢加。斯坦问丹尼斯，8万英镑是否足够让谢加安全返回且不问任何问题。丹尼斯同意与中间人交谈，中间人反过来也同意了这笔交易。通过丹尼斯，小偷指示斯坦将8万英镑现金放入丹尼斯的后备箱里
car along with a £10,000 finder's fee for Dennis. They were then instructed to drive the car to the village of Artna Crusher in County Clare and leave it in a specified remote location. There, the thieves would remove the money and replace it with instructions on how to retrieve Shergar. Officer Keirnians agreed to accompany Stan and Dennis in the hopes of catching the thieves in a sting operation. The trio followed the instructions, leaving Dennis's car in the specified location with
车里，外加给丹尼斯的1万英镑寻找费。然后他们被指示将车开到克莱尔郡的阿特纳克拉舍村，并把它留在指定的偏远地点。在那里，小偷将拿走钱并用如何取回谢加的说明取而代之。基尔尼恩斯警官同意陪同斯坦和丹尼斯，希望在一次钓鱼执法行动中抓获小偷。三人按照指示行事，将丹尼斯的车留在指定的地点，
£90,000 cash in the boot and then left the scene. They returned a short while later and found that the money had been taken, but there were no instructions regarding getting Shergar back. Upon realizing that the whole plot had been set up, Stan was convinced Officer Keirnians had been involved from the get-go. Officer Keirnians was investigated by the guarder and eventually sacked for carrying out under-the-table police operations. Dennis Minogue remained adamant that the horse he'd been shown was Shergar and opinions
后备箱里有9万英镑现金，然后离开了现场。他们不久后返回，发现钱已经被拿走了，但没有关于如何接回谢加的说明。意识到整个阴谋都是设定好的，斯坦确信基尔尼恩斯警官从一开始就参与其中。基尔尼恩斯警官遭到警方调查，最终因进行私下警察行动而被解雇。丹尼斯·米诺格仍然坚持他被展示的那匹马就是谢加，至于他和基尔尼恩斯警官是这场阴谋的一部分还是自己也被愚弄了，
differ as to whether he and Officer Keirnians were part of the setup or had been fooled themselves. The months continued to pass with no major breakthroughs. By September 1983, mares that had been lined up to breed with Shergar in the 1984 breeding season began arriving at Ballimani Stard, where they were to be bordered until definitive news regarding Shergar emerged. From the outset of the investigation, the guarder suspected that the IRA was involved in stealing Shergar. Throughout the 1970s, the IRA had started receiving weapons and training from international
各方意见不一。几个月过去了，仍然没有重大突破。到1983年9月，原定于1984年繁殖季与谢加配种的母马开始抵达巴利马尼牧场，在那里它们将被寄养，直到关于谢加的确切消息出现。从调查一开始，警方就怀疑爱尔兰共和军参与了偷谢加。在整个1970年代，爱尔兰共和军开始从国际
supporters including sympathizers from the United States, Libya and Palestine. However, their campaigns were costly and the amount of money coming in via donations and illegal activities wasn't enough to fund their violent protests, equipment, weapons and explosives. By the 1980s, the FBI was conducting an ongoing investigation into American support of the IRA, which meant there had been a halt on weapons procured from the USA. Consequently, the IRA was in financial strife and began resorting to kidnapping for ransom as a means of income with varying levels of success.
支持者（包括来自美国、利比亚和巴勒斯坦的同情者）那里获得武器和训练。然而，他们的行动代价高昂，通过捐款和非法活动获得的资金不足以资助他们的暴力抗议、设备、武器和炸药。到了1980年代，美国联邦调查局（FBI）正在对美国对爱尔兰共和军的支持进行持续调查，这意味着从美国采购的武器已经停止。因此，爱尔兰共和军陷入了财务困境，并开始诉诸绑架勒索赎金作为收入来源，取得了不同程度的成功。
In October 1981, the IRA had kidnapped a wealthy supermarket executive Ben Dunne after he pulled over in his car to offer assistance at a staged accident. Ben was held hostage for six days while negotiations were made for a £1.5 million ransom to be paid. His family wanted to pay the ransom but were blocked by the guarder, prompting Ben's property manager to pay instead to secure Ben's safe release. This kidnapping set a crucial precedent as the IRA earned a lucrative ransom without any consequences.
1981年10月，爱尔兰共和军绑架了一位富有的超市高管本·邓恩，当时他把车停在路边，在一场假装的事故中提供帮助。本被扣为人质六天，期间就支付150万英镑的赎金进行了谈判。他的家人想支付赎金，但遭到警方阻止，促使本的物业经理转而支付赎金以确保本安全获释。这次绑架设定了一个至关重要的先例，因为爱尔兰共和军在没有任何后果的情况下赚取了丰厚的赎金。
In August 1983, six months after Sherga was stolen, seven armed IRA members stormed the South Dublin House of Galen, Western, the wealthy president of a Canadian supermarket chain, intending to kidnap him for ransom. The guarder had already received a tip-off that Galen might be a target and were waiting inside to arrest them. A gunfight ensued, with five of the perpetrators taken into custody for attempted kidnapping while two escaped. Investigators believed these were the same individuals who had stolen Sherga, but they
1983年8月，在谢加被偷六个月后，七名武装爱尔兰共和军成员冲进都柏林南部的加伦·韦斯特（加拿大一家连锁超市的富有总裁）的宅邸，企图绑架他勒索赎金。警方已经接到线索称加伦可能是个目标，并在里面等待逮捕他们。随之爆发了一场枪战，五名肇事者因企图绑架被拘留，两人逃脱。调查人员认为这些人就是偷谢加的人，但他们
denied any involvement with the case. Three months later, the IRA abducted one of Galen's employees, a widowed father of four named Don Tidy. Don was driving his teenage daughter to school in the Dublin suburb of Rathbarnam when IRA members posing as the guarder pulled him over and shoved him in the boot of their fake police car. After a 22-day long investigation, Don was found unharmed with his captors in a wooded area of County Letram and a shootout followed, resulting in the deaths of a guarder trained
否认与此案有任何牵连。三个月后，爱尔兰共和军绑架了加伦的一名员工、一个有四个孩子的寡居父亲，名叫唐·蒂迪。唐正开车送他的十几岁女儿去学校，地点在都柏林郊区的拉思法尔纳姆，当时伪装成警察的爱尔兰共和军成员把他拦下，塞进他们假警车的后备箱里。经过长达22天的调查，唐在莱特姆郡的一个树林里被发现安然无恙，和他的绑架者在一起，随后发生了一场枪战，导致一名受过训练的警官
in E and an army private. The general consensus was that the IRA took Sherga as they had the motive and means to carry out the theft. But when the IRA didn't claim responsibility, some people doubted their involvement as they had always admitted to all their other kidnappings. Moreover, at the time Sherga was taken, a number of British intelligence agents had infiltrated the IRA and it was expected that one of them would have surely heard about the plan.
和一名陆军列兵丧生。普遍的共识是，爱尔兰共和军带走了谢加，因为他们有动机也有手段实施偷窃。但当爱尔兰共和军没有宣称负责时，一些人怀疑他们是否参与其中，因为他们过去总是承认他们所有的其他绑架事件。此外，在谢加被带走时，许多英国情报特工已经渗透到爱尔兰共和军中，人们预计其中一人肯定会听到这个计划。
Those who suspected the IRA was responsible have argued that British intelligence might have known but didn't speak up out of fear of putting their lives in jeopardy. It's also been suggested that the IRA may have never roamed up to the crime because the public outrage over Sherga's theft was so much more intense than the reaction to IRA kidnappings of people. It was argued that the IRA kept it a secret because they feared a huge backlash from the Irish community over the theft of the beloved horse. By the end of 1983, insurance companies began to pay out Sherga's various shareholders for
那些怀疑爱尔兰共和军负有责任的人认为，英国情报部门可能知道，但由于害怕危及生命而没有说出来。也有人认为，爱尔兰共和军可能从未承认过这起犯罪，因为公众对谢加被盗的愤怒远比对爱尔兰共和军绑架人的反应要强烈得多。有人认为，爱尔兰共和军将其保密，是因为他们害怕爱尔兰社会对这匹心爱的马被盗的强烈反对。到1983年底，保险公司开始向谢加的各股东赔付
their losses. Most of the shareholders had taken out insurance with Lloyds of London for over £10 million, which included coverage for Sherga's death as a result of accident, sickness or disease. Twenty of the shareholders had also paid extra premiums to cover theft, which resulted in each of them receiving a payout of £7 million. Those who didn't have coverage for theft didn't receive any payouts as it couldn't be proved whether or not Sherga was dead and therefore the insurance companies weren't obliged to pay.
他们的损失。大多数股东向劳合社投保了超过1000万英镑的保险，其中包括因事故、疾病或生病导致谢加死亡的保险。其中二十名股东还支付了额外的保费以承保盗窃，这导致他们每人获得了700万英镑的赔付。那些没有盗窃险的人没有得到任何赔付，因为无法证明谢加是否已死，因此保险公司没有义务支付。
Some of the wealthier shareholders took the issue to court but their claims were unsuccessful, which discredited some lingering theories that Sherga's theft was an inside job orchestrated by the shareholders in a bid to collect large insurance payouts. By 1984, the case had gone cold and on February 6, just prior to the commencement of the breeding season, the shareholders and Aga Khan released their first official statement. They confirmed their belief that the IRA was responsible for the crime and that Sherga had been killed shortly after he was stolen, describing his chances of being alive as remote. Eighteen months after Sherga's disappearance, Chief Inspector James Murphy told the Washington
一些较富有的股东将此问题诉诸法庭，但他们的诉求没有成功，这消除了人们对谢加被盗是由股东精心策划的内部工作以骗取巨额保险金的挥之不去的理论。到1984年，案件已经陷入僵局，2月6日，就在繁殖季开始前夕，股东和阿迦汗发布了他们的第一份官方声明。他们确认他们相信爱尔兰共和军应对这起犯罪负责，并且谢加在被偷后不久就被杀害了，形容他生还的机会微乎其微。谢加失踪十八个月后，总督察詹姆斯·墨菲告诉《华盛顿
Post, quote, You have to take into account more serious things. A person's life is involved in a murder, not a horse's. But we keep looking. You can never feel dispirited, though you have to take into account the lapse of time. We follow up on anything. You can't call the case closed until it is. He's continued to abound as to Sherga's fate.
邮报》：“你必须考虑到更严重的事情。这是一条人命牵涉到谋杀，而不是一匹马。但我们一直在找。你永远不会感到气馁，尽管你必须考虑到时间的流逝。我们跟进任何事情。在案件结案之前，你不能称之为结案。”关于谢加的命运，各种猜测依然层出不穷。
Some believed he was held in a private farm until the story died down, at which point he was disguised and raced under a different name in order to win money for his captors. This theory held a little credit, as there was no guarantee that Sherga would have performed after several years without training, and nor could he have been disguised well enough to prevent people from recognizing him. Another theory was that Sherga had been stolen for breeding purposes. This too was easily dismissed, as the profits derived from breeding with a famous racehorse came almost entirely from the name attached to the horse.
有人认为他被关在一个私人农场里，直到事情平息下来，届时他被伪装并以不同的名字参加比赛，以便为绑架者赢得金钱。这个理论有一点可信度，因为不能保证谢加在没有训练几年后还能表现出色，而且他的伪装也不足以阻止人们认出他。另一个理论是谢加被偷是为了繁殖。这也很快被驳回，因为用一匹著名的赛马进行繁殖所获得的利润几乎完全来自于附属于这匹马的名字。
Without revealing that Sherga was the father, any offspring he bore would be worth a fraction of the cost. Some believed a Middle Eastern shake had stolen Sherga to breed his own successful racehorses, but this theory was also dismissed, given the sheer effort it would have taken to secretly transport the horse internationally. Authorities did investigate this claim, but found no evidence to suggest a horse had been chartered out of the country by sea or air around the time of Sherga's disappearance. It was also speculated that the mafia may have been responsible.
如果不透露谢加是父亲，他生下的任何后代都只值一小部分成本。有人认为一个中东酋长偷了谢加来繁殖他自己的成功赛马，但由于秘密将马国际运输所需付出的巨大努力，这个理论也被驳回了。当局确实调查了这一说法，但没有发现任何证据表明在谢加失踪前后有马通过海运或空运被包机运出国外。也有人推测黑手党可能负有责任。
In the months before Sherga's theft, a French bloodstock agent named Jean-Michael Gambit, who was living in the United States, had been in talks with the Aga Khan about purchasing a racehorse. It was speculated that Jean-Michael didn't have the money to buy the horse up front, so he obtained a loan of half a million dollars from the New Orleans mafia. The deal with the Aga Khan then fell through, but Jean-Michael had already spent the money and couldn't afford to repay the mafia. On December 13, 1982, Jean-Michael was shot dead in his car and the vehicle set alight.
在谢加被盗前几个月，一个居住在美国的法国血统经纪人让-米歇尔·甘比特一直在与阿迦汗就购买赛马进行谈判。据推测让-米歇尔没有钱预付买马的钱，于是从新奥尔良黑手党那里获得了50万美元的贷款。随后与阿迦汗的交易告吹，但让-米歇尔已经花掉了这笔钱，无力偿还黑手党。1982年12月13日，让-米歇尔在车内被枪杀，车辆被纵火烧毁。
The theory was that he had been killed by the mafia, who then stole Sherga as a means of repayment. However, the police ruled that Jean-Michael's death was a suicide, and he had staged the crime scene to look like a murder so his family could collect from his multiple life insurance policies. Neither the authorities nor the Aga Khan believed the two incidents were related. At one point, it was even speculated that Libyan political leader, Colonel Muammar al-Gaddafi, was responsible and was holding Sherga in Libya.
这个理论是他被黑手党杀死，黑手党随后偷了谢加作为偿还手段。然而，警方裁定让-米歇尔的死是自杀，他把犯罪现场伪装成谋杀，以便他的家人可以从他的多份人寿保险中索赔。当局和阿迦汗都不认为这两起事件有关联。一度甚至有人推测利比亚政治领袖穆阿迈尔·卡扎菲上校负有责任，并把谢加关在利比亚。
The theory was that Colonel Gaddafi had struck a deal with the IRA to steal Sherga in exchange for weapons because he was opposed to the Aga Khan's position as a Muslim spiritual leader, a position he felt he was much better suited to. It was argued that Colonel Gaddafi had decided to kidnap Europe's most famous force as a way to demonstrate the influence and power he held while causing the Aga Khan great embarrassment. This theory was rejected by authorities and Sherga shareholders as there was no evidence to suggest that Colonel Gaddafi even knew who Sherga was, let alone had anything to do with his kidnapping.
该理论称，卡扎菲上校与爱尔兰共和军达成了一项协议，用武器换取偷走谢加，因为他反对阿迦汗作为穆斯林精神领袖的地位，他觉得这个地位自己更适合。有人认为卡扎菲上校决定绑架欧洲最著名的马，以此来展示他拥有的影响力和权力，同时给阿迦汗带来巨大的尴尬。这一理论遭到当局和谢加股东的拒绝，因为没有任何证据表明卡扎菲上校甚至知道谢加是谁，更不用说与他的绑架有任何关系了。
There were also theories that Sherga may have been taken by someone who was jealous of his success. The Aga Khan had an ongoing rivalry with a Kentucky-based bloodstock agent named Wayne Murdy over a complicated horse sale in 1978 that had ultimately worked out in the Aga Khan's favour. Wayne had been furious, which led the media to report he may have retaliated against the Aga Khan by stealing Sherga. Wayne denied any involvement, and without any evidence to link him to the crime, the theory
还有理论认为谢加可能是被一个嫉妒他成功的人带走的。阿迦汗与一个驻肯塔基州的血统经纪人韦恩·默迪之间存在持续的竞争，起因是1978年一笔复杂的马匹买卖最终对阿迦汗有利。韦恩当时非常愤怒，导致媒体报道称他可能通过偷谢加来报复阿迦汗。韦恩否认了任何参与，在没有任何证据将他与犯罪联系起来的情况下，这个理论
dissipated over time. In an interview, Wayne admitted that he hated the Aga Khan enough that he would have relished pulling off Sherga's kidnapping, but emphasised he would never stoop that low. Years went by without any breakthroughs in the case. In July of 1997, the IRA called a final ceasefire, and on April 10, 1998, a treaty known as the Good Friday Agreement was signed, marking an end to the troubles. Over the course of the IRA's 30-year campaign, approximately 1,800 people were killed, including 640 civilians and 1,100 members of the British security forces, and an estimated 10,000 IRA
随着时间推移而消散。在一次采访中，韦恩承认他恨阿迦汗恨到足以享受策划谢加的绑架，但他强调他绝不会堕落到那种地步。案件多年来没有任何突破。1997年7月，爱尔兰共和军宣布最终停火，1998年4月10日，一项被称为《贝尔法斯特协议》的条约签署，标志着动荡时期的结束。在爱尔兰共和军长达30年的行动期间，大约有1800人丧生，其中包括640名平民和1100名英国安全部队成员，估计有10000名爱尔兰共和军
members were imprisoned at various times. The same year that the Good Friday Agreement was signed, an autobiography was published that claimed to reveal the truth about what happened to Sherga. Titled The Informant, the book was written by Sean O'Callaghan, a former senior member of the IRA who had also worked as a police informant for the guarder. In his book, O'Callaghan claimed that the IRA had been facing bankruptcy in the early 1980s and desperately needed money to further their campaigns, so renowned leading member of the IRA, Kevin Mallon, was tasked with the job of raising several million pounds.
成员在不同时期被关押。在签署《贝尔法斯特协议》的同一几年，一本自传出版了，声称揭示了关于谢加遭遇的真相。这本名为《告密者》的书由肖恩·奥卡拉汉撰写，他曾是爱尔兰共和军的高级成员，也曾担任过警方的线人。在他的书中，奥卡拉汉声称爱尔兰共和军在1980年代初面临破产，迫切需要资金来进一步开展行动，因此爱尔兰共和军的知名领袖凯文·马隆被委以筹集数百万英镑的任务。
O'Callaghan claimed that Mallon gathered a small team from Dublin to pull off the theft, including one IRA member named Jerry Fitzgerald. Two weeks after Sherga was taken, Fitzgerald confided in O'Callaghan that he was responsible and said only a handful of other people knew about the plot. According to Fitzgerald, just hours after the theft, Sherga became extremely distressed and started thrashing about. His captors were unable to calm him down and he eventually injured one of his legs. Not knowing what to do, the IRA members decided they had no choice but to shoot Sherga and then pretend he was still alive in order to collect the ransom money.
奥卡拉汉声称马隆从都柏林召集了一个小团队来完成这起盗窃，其中包括一名名叫杰瑞·菲茨杰拉德的爱尔兰共和军成员。在谢加被带走两周后，菲茨杰拉德向奥卡拉汉吐露他是负责人，并说只有少数其他人知道这个阴谋。据菲茨杰拉德说，就在盗窃发生几个小时后，谢加变得非常烦躁并开始疯狂挣扎。他的绑架者无法让他平静下来，他最终弄伤了其中一条腿。不知该如何是好，爱尔兰共和军成员决定他们别无选择，只能枪杀谢加，然后假装他还活着，以便收回赎金。
When they realized the syndicate wasn't going to pay without proof that Sherga was still alive, the group abandoned the plan and ceased all communications. O'Callaghan confirmed an ongoing theory that the thieves had made the mistake of thinking that the Aga Khan was Sherga's sole owner and would therefore be the only one deciding whether or not to pay the ransom. They also didn't think the theft would attract anywhere near the amount of media attention that it did. Summarizing the kidnapping, O'Callaghan said, quote, It was a total cock up from start to finish. Police documents from the time corroborate this story as there were reports that a small group of men from the IRA suddenly changed
当他们意识到辛迪加在没有谢加还活着的证据的情况下不会付钱时，该组织放弃了计划并停止了所有的沟通。奥卡拉汉证实了一个持续的理论，即小偷犯了一个错误，认为阿迦汗是谢加的唯一所有者，因此将是唯一决定是否支付赎金的人。他们也没想到偷窃会吸引到接近后来那么多的媒体关注。在总结这起绑架时，奥卡拉汉说：“从头到尾这完全是一团糟。”当时的警察报告佐证了这个故事，有报道称一小群来自爱尔兰共和军的人突然改变了计划
their behavior around the time that Sherga was taken. But no definitive evidence exists and O'Callaghan's claims have never been proven. In 1999, a movie titled Sherga was released based loosely on the events surrounding the theft and it went on to win the award for Best Foreign Film at the Temecula International Film Festival in California. That same year, a special race named the Sherga Cup was held at the Goodwood Race Course in West Sussex, England, to commemorate Sherga's memory. The race was designed to be a lighthearted competition with a unique racing format similar to the Ryder Cup in golf and the winners were presented with a silver statue of Sherga,
他们在谢加被绑架前后的行为。但并不存在确凿的证据，奥卡拉汉的说法也从未得到证实。1999年，一部名为《谢加》的电影上映，该片大致根据这起盗窃案前后的事件改编，并在加利福尼亚州的特梅库拉国际电影节上荣获最佳外语片奖。同年，在英国西萨塞克斯郡的古德伍德赛马场举行了一场名为“谢加杯”的特别赛马，以纪念谢加。这场比赛旨在成为一场轻松愉快的比赛，其独特的赛制类似于高尔夫球的莱德杯，获胜者将获赠一座谢加的银质雕像，
donated by the Aga Khan. The Sherga Cup was so popular that it became an annual event, which today is called the Dubai Duty Free Sherga Cup and is held at Ascot Race Course in England. In the spring of 2000, a council worker named Tommy Foley was clearing out a narrow valley in County Kerry Island when he found a rotting coalsack hidden underneath a rock. It was badly disintegrated, indicating it had been there for a significant amount of time. Tommy unwrapped the sack and inside, he discovered a horse's skull containing two bullet holes. Thinking it was Sherga, Tommy was beside himself and news quickly spread throughout town that Sherga had been found. Des Leiden, an equine veterinarian and clinical pathologist, was
由阿迦汗捐赠。谢加杯大受欢迎，以至于成为一项年度赛事，如今被称为迪拜免税店谢加杯，在英国阿斯科特赛马场举行。2000年春天，一名名叫汤米·弗利的市议会工作人员在凯里郡的一个狭窄山谷清理时，在一个岩石底下发现了一个腐烂的煤袋。它已经严重风化，表明它在那里呆了相当长的一段时间。汤米打开了袋子，在里面发现了一个带有两个弹孔的马头骨。以为那是谢加，汤米欣喜若狂，谢加被找到的消息迅速传遍了全城。德斯·莱登，一名马匹兽医和临床病理学家，是
called to examine the skull. A detailed examination revealed the skull belonged to a two-year-old horse, where a Sherga was five years old at the time he was stolen, ruling out the possibility that it was him. On January 27, 2008, the Sunday Telegraph newspaper published an article titled The Truth About Sherga Race Horse Kidnapping. The article expanded on IRA member-turned-police informant Sean O'Callaghan's story that Kevin Mallon had orchestrated the kidnapping. According to a source close to a former IRA member, the plan to kidnap Sherga had been sanctioned by the IRA's ruling body, the Army Council. The kidnapping plot had failed from the start because the vet who'd agreed to look after Sherga pulled out on the night of the theft.
被请来检查这个头骨的。详细检查显示，该头骨属于一匹两岁的马，而谢加被盗时已经五岁，这就排除了它是谢加的可能性。2008年1月27日，《星期日电讯报》发表了一篇题为《关于赛马谢加绑架案的真相》的文章。这篇文章详细阐述了前爱尔兰共和军成员转变为警方线人的肖恩·奥卡拉汉的故事，即凯文·马龙策划了这起绑架案。根据接近前爱尔兰共和军成员的消息来源，绑架谢加的计划得到了爱尔兰共和军统治机构——陆军委员会的批准。绑架计划从一开始就失败了，因为同意照顾谢加的兽医在偷窃当晚退出了。
Four days into the ransom negotiations, the Army Council decided it was too much trouble for little gain and told the IRA to release Sherga. By this point, the guarder were looking for Sherga all over Ireland and Kevin Mallon was under surveillance, making it impossible to transport the horse without getting caught. Mallon instead allegedly ordered that Sherga be shot and two handlers opened fire on him using a machine gun. According to the source, it was a, quote, very bloody death and it took several minutes for Sherga to succumb to his injuries. The article concluded, quote, And so, the greatest racehorse of the century was butchered in the same way that the IRA killed
在赎金谈判进行的第四天，陆军委员会认为这太麻烦而没有什么收益，并告诉爱尔兰共和军释放谢加。到了这个时候，守卫们正在全爱尔兰寻找谢加，而凯文·马龙也处于被监视之中，这使得在不被抓获的情况下运送这匹马变得不可能。据称，马龙转而下令枪决谢加，两名处理人员用机枪向他开火。据消息人士透露，这是一个“非常血腥的死法”，谢加花了整整几分钟才因伤身亡。文章最后总结道：“因此，本世纪最伟大的赛马就这样被屠杀了，就像爱尔兰共和军杀死
many of its human enemies. The source did not know exactly where Sherga's body was buried, but the fact that his carcass was riddled with bullets meant the gang did everything to ensure Sherga's remains were never found. Many in the Republic, including broad Republican sympathizers, would never have forgiven the IRA and its political wing, Shin Fein, for machine gunning the equine pride of the nation in cold blood. In 2017, the Royal Mail released a series of postage stamps featuring racehorse legends, including Sherga. The back of the pack read, In the summer of 1981, Sherga was the meteor that filled the racing sky. On August 29, 2019, Sherga's vet, Stan Cosgrove, passed away. He never received an
它的许多人类敌人一样。”消息来源并不知道谢加的尸体被埋在哪里，但他的尸体布满子弹这一事实意味着帮派做了一切事情来确保谢加的遗体永远不会被找到。共和国的许多人，包括广泛的共和党同情者，永远不会原谅爱尔兰共和军及其政治翼锋新芬党冷血地用机枪扫射这个国家的马匹骄傲。2017年，皇家邮政发行了一系列以赛马传奇为主题的邮票，其中包括谢加。邮票背面写着：“1981年夏天，谢加是划过赛马天空的流星。”2019年8月29日，谢加的兽医斯坦·科斯格罗夫去世了。他从未收到过
insurance payout for Sherga's theft and had been forced to sell his 120-acre farm to recoup costs involved with his shares in the horse, as well as the £80,000 he lost in the failed reward money scam. Stan was remembered as an extraordinary equine veterinarian, and for the work he did in trying to recover Sherga. Many believe Sherga's remains are most likely hidden in County Letram, a largely deserted area that covers a landmass of 1,590 square kilometers. At the time, the area was used for IRA training camps and to house members of the IRA who were on the run. In the 1980s, police secretly excavated some boggy areas in County Letram looking for Sherga, but with no success. Des Leiden, the equine veterinarian and clinical pathologist,
关于谢加被盗的保险赔付，为了弥补他持有的这匹马的股份所涉及的成本，以及他在失败的悬赏金骗局中损失的8万英镑，他被迫卖掉了他那120英亩的农场。斯坦被人们铭记为一位杰出的马匹兽医，并因他在试图寻回谢加方面所做的工作而受到缅怀。许多人相信谢加的遗体最有可能藏在利特里姆郡，这是一个面积达1590平方公里的大片荒芜地区。当时，该地区被用作爱尔兰共和军的训练营，并用于安置在逃的爱尔兰共和军成员。20世纪80年代，警方秘密挖掘了利特里姆郡的一些沼泽地以寻找谢加，但没有成功。德斯·莱登，这位马匹兽医和临床病理学家，
says he still receives skeletal remains from time to time that require testing to see if they belong to Sherga. A DNA profile for Sherga has been completed and is stored securely in case it is ever required to make a positive identification in the future. It was able to be completed because two veterinarian students had come forward following Sherga's theft to admit they'd plucked two hairs from Sherga's tail to keep his souvenirs while studying at Balimani Stud. To this day, the IRA has never claimed responsibility for stealing Sherga, although the Ghada, the Aga Khan, and a majority of Sherga's shareholders believe they were to blame. In recent times, it's been suggested that former IRA members still haven't acknowledged
表示他仍然不时收到需要测试的骨骼遗骸，以确定它们是否属于谢加。谢加的DNA图谱已经完成并被安全存储，以防将来需要进行确凿的身份鉴定。之所以能够完成，是因为两名兽医学生在谢加被盗后站出来承认，他们在巴利马尼种马场学习时，曾从谢加的尾巴上拔下两根毛发作为纪念品保留。直到今天，爱尔兰共和军从未声称对盗窃谢加负责，尽管加达、阿迦汗以及谢加的大多数股东都认为他们难辞其咎。近年来，有人提出前爱尔兰共和军成员至今仍未承认
their involvement because the troubles and the organization's terror tactics are a painful old wound that the people of Ireland want to move on from. The investigation into what happened to Sherga is no longer active, and former members of the IRA have no reason to come forward if they were responsible, as they'd only risk putting death below ex-comrades behind bars. Prior to Stan Cosgrove's death, he commented that the IRA's silence only served as proof that they were responsible. He believed that they chose to remain silent out of shame, regret, and the fear of bad publicity after realizing that they, quote, had done a repulsive thing to the Irish people.
他们的参与，是因为动荡局势和该组织的恐怖战术是一个痛苦的旧伤疤，爱尔兰人民希望抛开过去向前看。对谢加遭遇的调查已经不再活跃，爱尔兰共和军的前成员如果负有责任，也没有理由站出来，因为他们只会冒着将前战友置于死地或锒铛入狱的风险。在斯坦·科斯格罗夫去世之前，他曾评论说，爱尔兰共和军的沉默只能证明他们负有责任。他相信，他们选择保持沉默是出于羞耻、遗憾以及对坏名声的恐惧，因为他们意识到他们“对爱尔兰人民做了一件令人厌恶的事情”。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。